de commencer notre audition avec
monsieur le ministre délégué chargé du
logement que nous sommes très heureux
d'accueillir pour la première fois ici
dans cette salle de la commission des
affaires économiques du Sénat et donc je
pense que d'autres collègues vont
peut-être nous rejoindre c'est vrai
qu'il y a une séance importante en ce
moment dans l'hémicycle sur le projet de
loi immigration et que B chacun fait
comme il peut mais je pense que voilà
les gens vont arriver au fur et à mesure
et seront là pour à la fois écouter
monsieur le ministre et vous posz un
certain nombre de questions donc vous
êtes rattaché auprès du ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires donc vous venez
aujourd'hui plus spécifiquement nous
parler de votre projet de budget pour
2024 même si je pense que un certain
nombre de nos collègues seront amenés à
vous poser des questions beaucoup plus
larges que le seul budget pour l'année
2024 donc je précise que cette audition
est diffusée en vidéo en direct sur le
site internet du Sénat et qu'elle sera
disponible ensuite en vidéo à la demande
alors Monsieur le Ministre puisque c'est
la première fois que vous vous exprimez
devant notre commission je me permets de
vous présenter en quelques mots mais
vraiment quelques mots vous êtes né à
dunkererque ville dont vous avez été
adjointe au maire puis maire pendant
plus de 20 ans avant votre entrée au
gouvernement au mois de juillet dernier
faisant preuve ainsi d'un bel enra
vous êtes aussi ingénieur xon et
économiste spécialiste des questions du
marché du travail et de la politique de
la ville chère Viviane ce qui vous a
conduit à travailler à l'OCDE puis
auprès de notre collègue Jean-Pierre
Sueur pour son important rapport demain
la ville ainsi que dans les cabinets de
Madame Martine Aubri et de Monsieur
Claude Bartolone voilà pour cette
présentation succinte mais vous aurez
aussi si vous souhaitez rajouter
quelques mots sur votre parcours et
votre carrière bien évidemment vous
serez amené peut-être à le faire donc
dans ce contexte qui est marqué par une
crise du logement que je pour PIR dire
une crise du logement particulièrement
grave vous nous présentez cet après-midi
un budget s'inscrivant dans dans la
lancée des évolutions de ces dernières
années la notation des programmes 109
135 et 177 qui sont dédié au logement
est en progression de plus de 8 % pour
2024 en fait on doit distinguer
l'évolution des programmes 109 et 177
qui progressent moins vite que
l'inflation de celui du programme 135 le
programme 109 pour les plus habitués
d'entre nous porte sur les aides
personnelles au logement les APL et
représente l'essentiel des dép pens avec
près de 14 milliards d'euros le
programme
177 assure le financement de
l'hébergement d'urgence et du plan
logement d'abord il pèse désormais près
de 3 milliards d'euros mais reste
sous-doté d'environ 200 à 250 millions
d'euros enfin le programme 135 porte
notamment sur la subvention à l'ANA il
atteint
1,5 milliards d'euros augmentant de près
de 100 % cette année pour assurer la
transformation de ma prime renove et la
création de ma prime adapte au-delà de
ces données la question que l'on doit se
poser est de savoir si ce budget est à
la hauteur de la crise du logement que
nous affrontons ellizabeth bornne
s'était engagée dans son discours de
politique générale
à conclure un pacte de confiance avec le
mouvement
Hlm cet engagement est resté lettre
morte alors que l'explosion des taux
d'intérêt remet clairement en cause la
RLS le relèvement de la TVA sur le
logement social ou la réduction des aPL
l'équation mastrichienne reste la seule
boussole pourtant la Caisse des Dépôts
vient de publier ces perspectives où
elles estiment à 66000 logements neufs
par an la capacité de construction des
bailleurs pour le futur soit la moitié
de l'objectif
affiché le gouvernement promeut
également le logement intermédiaire ce
qui est un outil aussi non négligeable
en particulier dans des territoires
tendu mais vous le savez comme nous
monsieur le ministre ce sont d'abord et
avant tout des logements sociaux les
plus accessibles dont nous avons besoin
et plus particulièrement des pli de même
dans le secteur privé le PLF met en
œuvre les conclusions du CNR logement
qui drappe du voile de l'écologie des
coupes budgétaires déclinant la vision
selon laquelle la France dépense trop et
construirit encore trop de logements
bien loin de la réalité vécue dans nos
territoires ù l'accès au logement
devient un sujet d'inquiétude croissante
une bombe sociale c'est votre
prédécesseur qui avait parlé de bombe
sociale et politique risquant
d'alimenter le vote extrême c'est aussi
tout un secteur économique qui trinque
au jeux des vases budgétaire
communiquant la rénovation ne remplit
pas les carnets de commande des
promoteurs et du secteur du bâtiment
sachez monsieur le ministre que nous
serons donc particulièrement attentifs
au Sénat aux inflexions que vous
donnerez et à la manière dont vous
pourrez répondre aux besoins des
Français sur ce besoin prioritaire et de
première nécessité qui est celui du
logement je vous laisse donc maintenant
vous pr nous présenteer les grandes
lignes de votre budget pour 2024 et
ensuite je donnerai la parole à ma
collègue Anchin Larcher qui est
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
pour les crédits du logement ainsi que à
l'ensemble des collègues qui ah oui et
j'avais pas vu que notre collègue Nadia
sologou nous a rejoint je la remercie
puisqu'elle est rapporteur pour avis des
crédits du programme 177 au titre de la
commission des affaires sociales donc
après votre intervention monsieur le
ministre à la fois an chanarché et Nadia
sologou bon si elle ne souhaite pas
s'exprimer et ensuite bien sûr nos
collègues pourront prendre la parole à
tour de rôle et je pense que ils ne
manqueront pas de vous poser un certain
nombre de questions soit au regard du
PLF soit d'une façon beaucoup plus
largement sur la politique que vous
entendez mener pour essayer de de
répondre aux besoins des Français et
surtout de faire en sorte que cette
crise du logement et bien puisse
connaître des effets qui soient les plus
limités possibles et que l'on puisse
arriver à à retrouver dans notre pays un
parcours résidentiel qui est aujourd'hui
bloqué qui permett effectivement sur
tous les segments du marché du logement
et de l'habitat à nos concitoyens de
pouvoir trouver autant que faire se peut
un logement abordable et qui soit le
plus en en conformité avec leurs
attentes et leurs besoins voilà Monsieur
le Ministre la parole est à vous merci
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les les sénateurs et et
sénatrices pour compléter mon mon
portrait je dirais juste quelques
quelques mandats que j'ai eu l'occasion
quelques fonctions que j'ai eu
l'occasion de d'exercer au niveau
national euh j'étais euh président
également de de France ville durable
c'est ce sont des institutions qui
auxquelles je tiens c'est pour ça que je
me permets de les exprimer également on
a travaillé justement avec l'ensemble
des parties prenantes professionnelles
de la ville durable sur ce sur ce
concept et sur la façon de développer le
le le le travail sur la ville durable à
l'échelle locale j'étais président de la
la Fédération nationale des agences
d'urbanisme après avoir été beaucoup
plusôt directeur d'une agence
d'urbanisme j'ai été président aussi de
de la fite vous m'avez d'ailleurs
audition
il y a pas si longtemps que ça en fait
euh et puis et puis aussi un poste que
que j'ai exercé un temps et et qui a un
lien avec avec ma fonction aujourd'hui
j'étais amendé au CGEDD qui est devenu
igedd j'étais chargé du Logement et de
la politique de la ville et j'ai
notamment eu l'occasion après ma thèse
sur les dispositifs d'
fiscalinvestissement locatif de
travailler à l'évaluation de la
politique du logement avec Monsieur de
la rue et Monsieur le compte euh j'avoue
que c'était des c'était des missionz
importante et sur quelques sujets liés à
la politique du logement donc donc voilà
pour dresser le le le tableau complet ce
que je vous propose c'est à l'image de
ce que j'ai pu faire pour la pour la
commission des
finances peut-être en en en quelques
mots brosser plutôt euh la façon dont on
dont on aborde aujourd'hui la la
politique du logement et dépasser
simplement le casadre du du PLF mais
mais dresser dresser les les
perspectives pour les pour les semaines
et même les mois les mois qui viennent
euh je ne vous ferai pas l'injure de de
rappeler les quatre grands objectifs de
la politique nationale du logement un
objectif économique on en parle beaucoup
en ce moment à la fois lié à l'emploi
mais aussi à à cette idée que chacun
doit pouvoir accès au logement dont il
on besoin dans des conditions abordables
économiquement un enjeu environnemental
que l'ensemble du parc de logement
correspond ond aux enjeux de de
transition
écologique un enjeu social c'est
notamment les problématiques autour de
l'hébergement d'urgence mais aussi la
question de la de la dignité des
logements et de la décence des logements
et enfin un objectif territorial
finalement que la politique du logement
soit adaptée aux enjeux locaux et à la
spécificité de chacun des des
territoires évidemment cette ces quatre
grands objectifs de que du logement en
ce moment sont impactés par une
crise à multiples facèdes crise
conjoncturelle et structurelle et crise
crise qui touche finalement l'ensemble
des des éléments que je viens d'indiquer
bord une crise à dominante
conjoncturelle crise plutôt économique
avec une forte croissance des taux je
faisais encore l'exercice assez simple
quand on passe d'un taux de 1,2 à 4,2 %
c'est un prêt qu'on peut faire à la
banque qui avant était de 180000 € qui
d'un seul coup tombe à 130000 € donc à
un moment donné 50000 € de de perte de
pouvoir sur un prêt ça explique
largement auquel se rajoute une une
inflation sur le coût des matériaux
auquel se rajoute du coup et en
conséquence une forme d'attentisme euh
dans euh par exemple dans l'achat
immobilier on on a eu ce chiffre
récemment qui est assez intéressant
c'est qu'en fait sur les 40 % de baisse
des crédits immobiliers en fait il y a
15 % qui s'explique par le refus de prêt
mais 25 % qui s'explique par simplement
le fait qu'on va même pas voir le
banquier parce qu'on attend que les prix
baissent donc il y a un effet à la fois
euh économique mais un effet d'attente
euh de de la baisse des prix qui
amplifie évidemment la la la crise à à
caractère économique une crise également
de de l'hébergement d'urgence des
problématiques de copropri dégradé qui
s'ajoutent donc je le disais à une crise
plus structurelle finalement euh des des
enjeux qui ont changé avec le temps euh
si je prends quelques exemples la crise
covid qui a aussi profondément changé ce
qu'on attend de de son logement avec des
des problématiques par exemple comme le
comme le travail télétravail l'accès à
un espace extérieur une différenciation
entre les territoires qui est beaucoup
plus marqué beaucoup plus forte on voit
bien aujourd'hui que la situation
parisienne n'est pas la situation de
montluon de Lunéville n'est pas la
situation du Pays-Basque donc on voit
une différenciation plus forte des
enjeux de la politique du logement une
question de l'acceptabilité de la
construction par nos populations qui a
aussi évolué au cours au cours du temps
et les enjeux bien entendu de transition
écologique et énergétique les enjeux de
vieillissement de la population aussi
puisque un tiers de nos concitoyens aura
plus de 60 ans en 2050 alors que une
faible partie du parc de logement est
adapté à cette réalité aujourd'hui et
cette crise démographique et peut-être
celle dont on parle le moins mais qui va
être aussi l'une des plus fortes dans
les années dans les années qui viennent
donc crise conjoncturelle crise
structurelle qui nécessite évidemment de
de revoir les les la politique national
du logement alors la façon dont on a
essayé d'aborder ce défi cette je pense
que je pense qu'on peut le dire comme ça
c'est effectivement de de distinguer des
réponses de court terme j'ai envie de
dire rapide pour essayer d'amortir le
choc de la crise économique en
particulier quand on passe le taux de 1
2 à 42 on peut pas faire trop de de
miracle je l' évoqué tout à l'heure
néanmoins il y a nécessité d'amortir le
choc d'essayer de de quand même limiter
limiter la casse sur sur un notamment
sur la production de logement
aujourd'hui c'est la raison pour
laquelle vous retrouvez un certain
nombre d'éléments dans ce projet de loi
de finances le prix àau zéro qui est
recentré j'ai envie de dire pour des
questions dans le U pardon qui est
recentré j'en veie dire plus pour des
questions de construire là où on en a le
plus besoin mais élargi et renforcé
élargi parce que nous avons revu les
territoires ention et renforcé parce que
nous avons rendu d'abord les barêes ont
changé et nous avons élargi les publics
bénéficiaire un travail que nous menons
je vais assez vite hein sur les sur les
sur les mesures mais un travail que nous
menons actuellement avec Bruno Le Maire
en direction du gouverneur de la Banque
de France pour voir comment on peut
faire évoluer effectivement les critères
d'octroit des crédit immobilier je pense
en particulier au sous-critères
c'est-à-dire les sous-critères qui sont
à l'intérieur des marges des banques
aujourd'hui l'idée aussi et vous l'avez
dit madame la Présidente de de soutenir
le logement le locatif intermédiaire
vous avez vu des éléments dans ce projet
de loi de finance qui ouvre notamment le
logement locatif intermédiaire au fond
d'investissement et nous réfléchissons à
comment on peut rendre ce logement
locatif intermédiaire euh comment on
peut le rendre plus attractif pour ces
pour ces fonds d'investissement euh une
réflexion sur la fiscalité locative à
travers une mission parlementaire euh
qui a vocation à la fois à traiter c'est
un peu pour ça qu'elle a été lancée au
départ la question de la la fiscalité
des meublés touristiques mais qui a
aussi pour
vocation de poser la question de la
façon dont on arrive à inciter un
certain nombre de nos concitoyens à
encore investir dans le locatif privé
donc cette mission parlementaire qui
doit rendre ses conclusions mi-février à
vocation aussi à nous guider sur cette
réforme de la fiscalité locative que
beaucoup attendent qui doit permettre
aussi de de redonner de de l'appétit
pour l'investissement locatif privé le
logement locatif social vous l'avez cité
madame la Présidente qui a fait l'objet
d'un accord à Nantes avec le mouvement
Hlm autour d'uneidée
concilier la poursuite de la rénovation
énergétique vous savez que le parc de
logement
locatifs sociaux est plutôt en avance
par rapport au parcs privés en matière
de rénovation énergétique mais l'idée
c'était de garder le rythme de pouvoir
permettre aux bailleurs sociaux de
garder cette avance tout en ne
sacrifiant pas la production et donc
c'était le sens de notre accord avec le
mouvement HLM à travers un fond dédié à
la rénovation énergétique et des prêts
de la Caisse des Dépôts renforcés plutôt
du côté de de la production vous avez
également dans ce projet loi de finance
des éléments sur le foncier de premiers
éléments j'ai envie de dire avec
notamment toute une série d'abattnements
sur les plusvalues de de cession foncièr
mais ce travail sur le foncier est un
travail qui ne fait que commencer
puisqu'on en voit aujourd'hui
l'importance dans les dans les années
qui viennent euh et nous nous
poursuivons toute notre réflexion sur la
façon dont on pourra largement mobiliser
le le foncier à à à coup pertinent dans
les dans les années qui viennent
notamment par exemple par un travail de
renforcement de l'action des
établissements publics fonciers c'est
l'une des pistes évidemment que nous
nous poursuivons actuellement un plan
logement étudiant qui est en cours
d'élaboration à la fois on essayant de
mobiliser davantage le foncier
universitaire en essayant aussi
peut-être de développer les les
colocations étudiantes au sein des
bailleurs sociaux notamment pour les
grands logements
et transformation également de de bureau
en logement étudiant transformation de
bureaux en logement familiaux a toujours
toujours été difficile techniquement et
financièrement c'est plus facile en
terme de résidence étudiant donc ce plan
est en cours d'élaboration et enfin
évidemment vous l'avez en tête ce plan
de rachat ou de
soutien à la à la production
à travers le le rachat de 47000
logements 17000 logements par la Caisse
des dépôts et 30000 logements par Action
Logement qui est toujours en
cours et dont on essaie de de penser la
la poursuite pour l'année 2024 donc ça
j'ai envie de dire c'est des des mesures
d'amortissement du choc de la crise
macro-économique que dont certaines sont
intégré à travers ce projet de loi de de
finance bien entendu il s'agit aussi de
mieux mobiliser le parc existant donc on
a évidemment donc le débat sur la
question des meublés touristiques pas
simplement la question de la fiscalité
mais surtout le fait que ces meublés
touristiques sont particulièrement
attractifs pour les investisseurs et
donc génèent une attrition de logement
les le logement étudiant par exemple a
beaucoup pati du développement des des
meublés touristiques et donc une
proposition de loi doit atterrir à
l'Assemblée nationale dans une niche
prévue en en décembre de manière à
pouvoir apporter au aux collectivités
locales et en particulier aux communes
un outil de régulation qui doit
permettre de sécuriser la régulation de
ce marché par les communes qui me semble
être l'outil le plus pertinent parce que
à la fois les communes qui en ont le
plus besoin pour en s'en saisir et de
manière sécurisée sur le plan juridique
parce que par exemple samintalo
aujourd'hui utilise le quota mais n'est
pas du tout sûr de pouvoir gagner en
justice par exemple donc l'idée c'est de
donner un package qui sécurise les
communes dans la régulation des meublés
touristiques et à la limite les communes
qui n'en ont pas besoin ou qui au
contraire sont contents de voir se
développer les meublés touristiques
parce qu'ils ont beaucoup de vacances et
ben ne l'utiliseront pas et donc ça
permettra aussi de garder cette
différenciation d'action et puis euh la
fiscalité et bien ce sera j'ai envie de
dire une question qui pourra être posée
après cette mission parlementaire sur la
réforme de la fiscalité locative il y a
également tout un travail de lutte
contre la vacance qui se poursuit à
travers la taxe sur les logements
vacants le le prêt à tau zéro euh en
zone détendue sur l'ancien rénové la
start-up zéro logement vaccant qui a été
mise en place et qui permet au maire
d'avoir une connaissance des
propriétaires euh des logements vacants
et de pouvoir intervenir directement
enfin je détaille pas le le plan de
lutte contre la vacance essayz aussi
d'insister sur la mobilité à l'intérieur
du parc social je l'ai notamment évoqué
lors de mon discours à Nant au Congrès
HLM un certain nombre de bailleurs ont
des politiques de mobilité euh
particulièrement pertinentes à avec des
résultats l'idée c'est que l'ensemble
des bailleurs sociaux puisse
effectivement se saisir de ces bonnes
pratiques pour pouvoir les développer
eux-mêmes je n'oublie jamais que sur les
2,4 millions de demandeurs du parc
social un/3 sont déjà dans le un/ers est
déjà dans le parc social et donc on a un
enjeu de 800000 demandeurs aujourd'hui
dans le parc social d' mutation interne
évidemment la question de l'habitat
indigne et des copropriétés dégradées
vous avez vu le rapport comm mis par
Michel Ludz et Mathieu anotin donc sur
l'habitat indigne et les copropriétés
dégradées il nous sert de référence
aujourd'hui pour préparer un plan à
caractère plutôt réglementaire et
financier avant la fin de l'année mais
également un projet de loi sur
lescopropriété dégradé l'habitat indine
qui a vocation à arriver sur vos table
au premier trimestre 2024 qui doit
permettre d'accélérer et de simplifier
l'action sur les copropriétés dégradées
c'est
la volonté aussi de de de réduction du
nombre de de passoirs thermiques à
travers évidemment ma primim Renov
renforcé 5 milliards d'euros dédiés à la
rénovation énergétique des logements
prévus en 2024 donc 400000 € sur le parc
social 4,6 milliards sur le parc privé
géré par
Lana ma primadapte qui est créé
effectivement et qui doit permettre de
s'adresser notamment pour l'adaptation
au vieillissement et et au handicap
évidemment c'est évoqué également le la
politique toujours à un très haut niveau
du parc d'hébergement d'urgence cela
j'ai envie de dire c'est pour répondre à
court terme et le plus rapidement
possible à des enjeux de de crise à
caractère à la fois conjoncturel mais
déjà des éléments structurel vous l'avez
repris mais euh il y a aussi une autre
ambition derrière et que nous nous
souhaitons commencer la concertation sur
une réflexion plus approfondie après la
vocation et ça a été annoncé par le
président de la République de la
proposition d'une grande loi logement
enfin grande d'une loi logement au
printemps
2024 dont le sens est d'essayer
justement d'adapter les outils de la
politique du logement au nouveau modèle
de développement territorial que nous
souhaitons pour l'avenir je l'ai évoqué
tout à l'heure il y a de nouveaux enjeux
la transition écologique qui s'associe
notamment la problématique du
zan le le vieillissement
le lien emploi logement qui a beaucoup
changé aussi la donne en matière de
politique du logement tout ça donc a
généré un un contexte nouveau qui remet
en cause le modèle de développement tel
qui s'est fait depuis plus de 70 ans
avec une énergie peu chè ou un carburant
peu cher et donc qui a vocation à penser
autrement l'urbanisme de nos de nos
territoires et donc évidemment il faut
des outils de la politique du logement
qui s'adaptent à cette nouvelle réalité
alors cette nouvelle réalité je le
disais tout à l'heure ça commence par la
différenciation qui dit différenciation
de politique du logement suivant le
territoire pose la question de la
décentralisation et donc évidemment dans
cette loi logement un chapitre sera
largement consacré à la décentralisation
de la politique du logement quel est le
niveau pertinent pour quelle ressources
pour quelle compéten avec quelle boîte à
outil de la régulation du marché du
logement telleles sont les questions qui
seront posées par ce chapitre dédié à la
décentralisation de la politique du
logement mais nous pourrons aussi poser
dans cette question de loi logement sur
le sens du logement social demain est-ce
que nous sommes toujours bien d'accord
sur la spécificité du modèle français
d'un modèle généraliste et non un modèle
résiduel est-ce que c'est pas tant
collectivement et politiquement de se
poser la question de l'affirmation du
modèle que nous souhaitons pour le
logement social en tout cas cette loi
logement pourrait permettre donc
justement d'adapter les outils par
exemple les modalit é d'attribution des
logements en fonction du modèle
effectivement qui paraît essentiel et
puis des questions qui peuvent être
connexe et qui ont vocation à à à à j'ai
envie dire adapter la politique du
logement à ces nouveaux enjeux tout à
l'heure par exemple je parlais beaucoup
du du foncier on voit que ça va devenir
un élément clé des stratégies de
politique du logement dans les années
qui viennent aujourd'hui les outils ne
sont pas à la hauteur de cet enjeu futur
cette loi logement doit contenir les
nouveaux outils fonciers dont les
collectivités don vent pouvoir se saisir
demain pour pouvoir mieux adapter leur
leur développement voilà madame la la
Présidente j'ai pas évoqué un certain
nombre de choses où j'ai pas voulu
rentrer mais voilà en tout cas je suis
je suis à l'écoute de de vos
questions merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre donc je vais laisser la parole
à notre rapporteur pour avis sur la
mission logement Anne chin Larcher
oui merci madame la Présidente merci
merci aussi monsieur le ministre nous
avons comme vous pouvez l'imaginer
auditionner un certain nombre de
d'acteurs du logement euh et le le
rapport ne tardera pas à venir à la fois
sur les nouvelles dispositions que que
que vous mettez dans ce projet loi de
finance concernant le Pinel et le PTZ
qui pose un certain nombre
d'interrogations euh j'ai trois petites
questions à vous poser la première
portera sur la situation des enfants la
rue les associations en ont compté 2822
en octobre de cette année soit 50 % de
plus que l'an passé ce chiffre
correspond au nombre de demandes
infructueuses adressé aux services
intégrés d'accueil et d'orientation les
SIAO les mineurs véritablement à la rue
seraient beaucoup moins nombreux de
l'ordre de 200 selon le décompte des
nuits de la solidarité mais le nombre
des enfants placés dans les situations
d'hébergement extrêmement préoccupante
en bidonville chez des tiers ou caché
serait peut-être CIN fois plus
importante que le chiffre des
associations j'ai tenu à donner ces
précisions car le sujet me paraît
humainement trop grave pour polémiquer
sur des chiffres mais je voudrais que
vous nous indiquiez comment vous comptez
y apporter des solutions est-ce que
l'augmentation du nombre de places
d'hébergement et par exemple une option
que vous pourriez retenir ou
privilégiez-vous d'autres voies ma
seconde question porte sur la crise de
la construction neuve la situation des
promoteurs comme de l'ensemble du
secteur du bâtiment est extrêmement
préoccupante vous l'avez d'ailleurs très
bien décrite avec un effondrement des
ventes et des mises en chantier al
l'horizon de 2 ans ce sont 300000
emplois qui sont menacés et certainement
un grand nombre d'entreprises qui vont
faire faillite sans compter les Français
qui ne pourront pas trouver où se loger
les promoteurs proposent de rééditer sur
un ou 2 ans la mesure baladure de
1993 pour exhonorer de droits de
transmission des logements neufs à
acheter pour en faire une résidence
principale qu'en pensez-vous cela
pourrait booster de nouveau la
construction de logement ou bien
proposez-vous d'autres solutions enfin
dernière petite question nous avons
entendu sur le logement locatif
intermédiaire vous assouplissez vous
faites en sorte également qu'il se
développe ne pensez-vous pas qu'il
serait temps pour les collectivités que
celui-là soit comptabilisé dans
l'ensemble des logements
sociaux merci voilà monsieur le ministre
je propose de répondre dors et déjà
notre rapporteur pour avis après on
ouvrira le champ des questions à nos
collègues merci euh merci alors
euh la question de l'hébergement
d'urgence qui qui rejoint évidemment la
problématique des enfants à la rue c'est
c'est évidemment Connex
euh je je je je pense qu'on on est sans
doute arrivriver à un moment où il faut
que collectivement on on se pose la
question finalement depuis un certain
nombre d'années pour différentes raisons
euh le le le choix a été fait de
l'augmentation du nombre de places
d'hébergement d'urgence nous sommes
passés en en 10 ans à 93000 places de
93000 places d'hébergement d'urgence à
203000 places d'hébergement d'urgence
donc plus qu'un doublement du nombre de
places d'hébergement d'urgence et ce
malgré la réussite reconnu par toutes
les associations du plan logement
d'abord qui a été mise en œuvre au au
précédent quinquena et qui a permis à
440000 personnes à la rue de retrouver
un logement donc malgré le succès de la
politique du logement d'abord nous
sommes passés de 93000 places à 203000
places aujourd'hui nous avons des
situations dans l'hébergement d'urgence
qui durent trop longtemps et finalement
l'explication de ce de cette
augmentation de l'hébergement d'urgence
se résume dans la phrase suivante un
flux entrant mais pas assez de flux
sortant et ce malgré la politique du
logement d'abord et c'est la raison pour
laquelle ce matin j'ai eu l'occasion
d'annoncer un renfort des effectifs de
la veille social de 500 postes
c'est-à-dire qui correspond à 1/3
d'effectifs supplémentaires ce qui est
considérable pour à la fois répondre aux
problématiques du 115 qui avait
effectivement du mal à suivre la
croissance du parc d'hébergement
d'urgence mais aussi et surtout
améliorer les marodes et améliorer
l'accomagne social et l'orientation des
personnes à la rue je pense que il faut
renforcer tout la comppaement qui permet
de sortir les personnes de l'hébergement
d'urgence moi je quen devenant ministre
j'ai été choqué de voir que des
personnes pouvaient être 5 ans à
l'hôtel
Le d'ailleurs je l'ai découvert sur
France 2 qui est venu m'interroger qui a
fait un reportage sur une famille
gabonnaise qui était à l'hôtel avec
plusieurs enfants scolarisés en France
et était à l'hôtel depuis 5 ans et moi
je leur ai répondu de manière tout à
fait transparente et honnête que ce qui
me choquait c'est qu'une famille puisse
être pendant 5 ans dans l'hébergement
d'urgence donc je pense que la
problématique de fond se situe là et
donc on peut effectivement répondre à
chaque fois avec l'augmentation du
nombre de places et bien entendu dans
l'urgence il y a cette réponse mais je
pense que nous devons réfléchir
collectivement à la moyen dont dont on
va pouvoir mieux accompagner ses
familles pour pouvoir proposer des
solutions de logement pour pouvoir
proposer des solutions diverses et
variées les situations sont très
hétérogènes et je pense qu'il
nécessitent un suivi plus précis donc je
me permettrai de répondre à votre
question c'est que oui la réponse du
gouvernement est l'augmentation du
nombre de placees d'hébergement
d'urgence parce que quand il y a urgence
il faut répondre et effectivement c'est
ce qui a été fait et c'est ce qui est
encore fait puisqu'il y a encore pour
2000 204 une prévision d'augmentation du
nombre de places d'hébergement d'urgence
notamment des places d'hébergement dédié
aux femmes à la rue plus
particulièrement mais je pense qu'il est
temps que nous pensions
collectivement une autre façon de gérer
la sortie de l'émergement d'urgence
c'est la raison pour laquelle je vous
disais nous avons renforcé d'un tiers
les effectifs dédiés à la veille sociale
avec
aussi je le souhaite à travers ce
renforcement d'effectif une meilleure
visibilité des solutions qui doivent
nous permettre demain de diminuer
finalement le stock si vous me permettez
l'expression mal venue mais réelle de
l'hébergement d'urgence
aujourd'hui après vous savez de quel
territoire je suis issu
d'unkererque il y a notamment l'été des
enfants à la rue à vinkererque beaucoup
ce sont ceux qui se retrouvent sur les
smallbats la
nuit il y a des situations particulières
mais et et et nous avons souhaité les
protéger il y a refus vous connaissez la
difficulté de de ces situations
spécifiques donc c'est effectivement une
situation que je connais
particulièrement bien sur mon territoire
donc voilà un petit peu ma ma réponse à
votre première interellation mais qui
qui je pense est une question centrale
qui doit nous animer dans dans les
années qui viennent sur la production
neuve je je je pense que nous n'aurons
pas ou nous n'aurons plus plus jamais
une recette
miracle 2008 on a sorti le seller du
chapeau un nouveau dispositif d' fiscale
ultra ultra
incitatif il
a il a permis effectivement d'écouler la
production neuve on a vu ensuite ce que
ça a donné et finalement parfois dans
des métropoles des programmes de
promotion immobilière qui était à 80 %
dédié à de l'investissement locatif et
finalement cette solution qui a toujours
consisté à dire on ne va pas crever la
bulle du prix immobilier qui est
toujours toujours de plus en plus haut
on l'entretient à un moment donné ben on
donne à nos successeurs finalement une
situation encore plus dégradée avec un
prix du foncier qui est tellement monté
un prix immobilier qui a tellement monté
qu'aujourd'hui on a totalement décroché
du pouvoir d'achat immobilier de nos
concitoyens et on arrive à une situation
effectivement qui est carrément
dramatique à un moment donné donc je
pense qu'à un moment la la la solution
qui consiste à dire il y aura une bonne
solution je n'y crois pas je pense qu'il
faut qu'on travaille sur l'ensemble des
éléments c'est la raison pour laquelle
vous m'avez entendu égrainer l'accession
à la propriété j'ai pas cité le BRS
d'ailleurs j'aurais pu citer d'autres
éléments mais l'accession à la propriété
l'investissement locatif moi j'y crois
encore pour les institutionnels et pour
les particuliers et je pense que le
travail sur la réforme de la fiscalité
locative doit nous permettre d'apporter
des éclairages sur les particuliers et
nous travaillons actuellement sur les
institutionnels et sur sur le logement
locatif social je pense que nous
arriverons nous devons maintenant nous
dire que la solution Mirac qui consiste
à sortir des des programmes de promotion
fondés ou en tout cas avec un produit
ultra dominant je pense qu'il faut
arrêter et qu'il faut retrouver un
équilibre dans les programmes de
promotion entre entre ce qui a toujours
constitué les fondamentaux la mesure
baladure son évaluation n'est pas
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de dire unanime
elle n'a elle n'a
pas elle n'a pas donné forcément les
résultats qu'on qu'on espère enfin qui
était espéré à l'époque c'est une mesure
parmi d'autres je ne suis pas certain
qu'elle produise en tout cas qu'elle
soit le le le miracle magique qui
permettrait de résoudre la crise
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il y a plusieurs
mesures aujourd'hui qui sont du même
niveau du même acabi on ne pourra pas
toutes les faire il faut essayer de de
sélectionner mais on essaie de
travailler en ce moment notamment on
travaille beaucoup sur le logement
lecatif intermédiaire et c'est ça qu'on
essaie effectivement de de pousser enfin
euh le le le dernier élément que que que
vous évoquez c'est le logement locatif
intermédiaire dans le compte SRU c'est
c'est ce que j'ai compris de de votre
dernière
question ça me rappelle ma jeunesse
euh l'objectif du du de la loi SRU était
le développement du logement social
c'est-à-dire un rééquilibrage la
production du du logement social à
l'échelle nationale cette loi enfin je
la défends et pour cause cette loi
fonctionne aujourd'hui un logement
social sur deux en France vient de la
loi
SRU alors certains vont dire ça va pas
assez vite d'autres vont dire ça va trop
loin c'est pas assez souple mais infin
année après année ça rééquilibre le
logement social sur le territoire et
quand on regarde la production de
logements sociaux en France quand un
logement social sur deux aujourd'hui est
construit grâce à la loi SRU on se dit
qu'on on a là un outil quand même assez
précieux pour le développement du
logement locatif social que vous
évoquiez madame la Présidente donc je
j'ai tendance à dire méfions-nous de la
boîte de Pandor que l'on pourrait ouvrir
sur la loi
SRU à à aujourd'hui elle produit des
résultats il y a des dispositifs qui
permettent de déroger il y a une
commission nationale qui permet de
d'examiner des situations moi je suis
très favorable à à à dire que
doivent-être exonéré d'un certain nombre
de responsabilités des communes qui
jouent le jeu c'est-à-dire qui
effectivement sent en des logiques de
développement du logement social donc je
pense qu'il faut tenir compte
effectivement de la volonté de faire ce
ce rattrapage mais je pense que nous
avons besoin vous l'avez dit madame la
Présidente nous avons besoin de
logements locatifs sociaux
et voilà et et le lli n'est pas tout à
fait dans dans dans ces critères là à
mon sens voilà alors après que l'on
réfléchisse au produits du logement
social demain c'est-à-dire est-ce qu'il
faut toujours plai plus pls euh est-ce
que c'est toujours pertinent d'avoir
trois trois trois produits pourquoi pas
on peut on peut demain réfléchir à au
aux outils je parlais tout à l'heure
j'aiévoqué la loi logement ça peut être
l'occasion de de parler des de ces
produits est-ce que c'est toujours
pertinent de distinguer le pli du plus
est-ce que c'est toujours pertinent de
voilà de distinguer le pls du LLI
effectivement euh voilà donc il peut y
avoir effectivement des des réflexions
mais aujourd'hui euh la la vocation
n'est pas de d'intégrer le pli dans le
dans les comptes SRU voilà on a déjà
réussi au moment de la loi élan à mettre
le BRS dans le quotat des logements
sociaux ce qui était déjà bien voilà
donc est- ce qui était aussi largement
attendu par par les maires en
particulier alors Nadia sologou
finalement veut intervenir donc elle est
rapporteur pour avis au nom de la
commission des affaires sociales sur le
programme
177 oui merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre pour pour votre éclairage et et
en effet je je me réjouis de de voir que
vous avez bien dit que c'est cette cette
situation des des personnes en
vulnérables l'hébergement des personnes
vulnérables et bien pour vous un
problème central alors par contre je
m'interroge parce que vous avez proposé
des nouveaux outils en disant par
exemple de créer 40000 nouvelles places
en intermédiation locative grâce à la
mobilisation des collectivités et des
associations spécialisé mais ne
craignez-vous pas que ces 40000
nouvelles places en fait ne soient pas
des nouvelles places que ce soit
simplement des places qui soit dirigé
vers une autre un autre public mais
retiré de l'offre pour un public qui est
déjà en tension pour trouver des des des
logements je pense par exemple aux
logements communaux si les collectivités
territoriales jouent le le jeu moi je
suis élu dans un territoire rural mettre
les logements communaux à disposition
via l'intermédiation locative des
populations vulnérables en fait c'est
des logements qui sont retirés de la
location pour d'autres populations donc
c'est c'est ça ça transfèt un en quelque
sorte le problème mais ça ça ça règle
pour une forme de population mais en
même temps ça amplifie la tension pour
pour d'autres c'est quand même 40000
places et puis la deuxième chose j'ai
j'ai bien entendu les 500 postes créés
pour l'accompagnement donc est-ce que
c'est pour cette raison que la la
tendance sur les années futures alors
autant cette année je je note dans les
les budgets l'effort qui est fait mais
la tendance pour 2025 et 2026 est
baissière par contre
donc je voulais la trajectoire
financière et baissière sur ces sur ces
crédits qui sont qui sont annoncés donc
est-ce que c'est parce que vous pensez
que les choses vont se
stabiliser voilà je vous
remercie j'is dire la tendance baissière
vient de la réflexion qu'on aura et que
j'aiévoqué tout à l'heure
c'estàd au fond je viens de l'évoquer en
plus à l'Assemblée nationale dans une
cuag au fond on ne peut pas se
satisfaire de 203000 places
d'hébergement d'urgence au fond au fond
et au fond on peut pas se satisfaire de
personnes qui restent 2 ans 3 ans 4 ans
5 ans dans l'hébergement d'urgence donc
j'ai envie de dire la tendance baissière
pourrait être un objectif ça veut dire
qu'on aurait réussi à mieux intégrer ces
personnes dans le logement et donc elle
part sur l'idée que nous allons réussir
à mettre en place notamment à travers
ces 500 effectifs complémentaires un
meilleur accompagnement vers le logement
donc elle suppose un meilleur
fonctionnement de nos Sao elle suppose
un meilleur accompagnement social elle
suppose voilà on va dire qu'on on
présuppose le succès de toute la
réflexion que j'évoqué tout à l'heure
donc d'où la tendance baissière voilà
sur
sur sur l'objectif que vous enfin sur le
l'élément que vous soullignez tout à
l'heure moi je vais je vais je je vais
être clair là-dessus l'ambition il faut
il faut il faut qu'on produise davantage
de logement et il faut qu'on produise
davantage logement locatifs sociaux je
qu'il n'y ait pas d'ambiguïé par rapport
à mon discours c'est pas une vocation de
il y a pas de volonté de la part du
gouvernement aujourd'hui de produire
moins je je le dis clairement je préfère
je préfère que que ce soit clair je je
ne pense pas qu'on ait besoin par
exemple que seulement 200000 logements
par an même si je même si je ne suis pas
certain qu' chiffre national est une
pertinence parce que pour moi il y a que
des chiffres locaux qui ont des pertin
qui une pertinence mais il faut
construire en clair même pour être plus
précis il y a des territoires
aujourd'hui où il faut privilégier du
recyclage parce que il y a des de la de
la vacance même parfois beaucoup de
vacances et donc il faut des nouveaux
outils qui nous permettent d'aller
reconquérir des logements qui
aujourd'hui sont vacants ou obsolèes et
il faut aller les chercher mais il y a
des territoires aujourd'hui où il faut
construire construire construire de
manière importante donc donc c'est vrai
que ça n'a jamais été aussi différencié
sur le territoire national mais il y a
des territoires où il faut construire
donc là-dessus pas d'ambiguïé en tout
cas sur la volonté d'une substitution à
du logement existant il faut construire
de toute manière
oui parce que monsieur le ministre vous
évoquez le fait que on ne se satisfait
pas et au combien de d'avoir des
familles qui peuvent rester 5 ans à
l'hôtel mais il y a pas qu'un
accompagnement social qu'il faut mener
auprès d'ell c'est pour qu'elle puisse
en sortir c'est qu'il faut qu'il y ait
une offre de de logement adapté et donc
on en revient toujours au point de
départ en disant qu'il faut continuer à
à construire plus
particulièrement dans ce domainelà
peut-être des des pli ou des personnes
des des logement qui leur permettent
effectivement au vu de leur de leur
revenu de leur ressources de pouvoir
aspirer à un logement alors on va passer
aux questions de nos collègues première
question de guidin
Cambier merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre je voulais vous
interroger en particulier sur l'objectif
territorial ce 4e objectif que que vous
annoncez qui vise à s'adapter à la
réalité du territoire euh j'ai eu
l'occasion de de visiter en effet encore
il y a peu d'un déplacement un certain
nombre de communes qui étaient touché
dans la ruralité de manière à pas couper
justement ou de pas faire le cission
entre la préhension dans l'urbain la
préhension dans le rural de de cette
problématique du logement et ce qu'on
constate malheureusement c'est que trop
souvent la ruralité se sent encore une
fois un peu la grande oubliée de ces de
ces politiques la ruralité c'est pas la
maison individuelle en zone détendue
sont les spécificités particulières ce
sont des questions très prignantes
d'habitat vacant de problème
d'indivision de succession de bâtis
ancien dégradé de friche et cetera de
dents creuses et tout ça bien sûr ça
motive en même temps la vie de la
commune son dynamisme son renouvellement
également alors les financements publics
pour le logement en milieu rural c'est
vrai qu'ils sont ils sont souvent assez
assez rare et il représenteent trop
souvent deux à trois fois le prix du
bien euh nettement plus même dans les
zones dans les zones en déprise et il
faut toujours batailler pour que des
dispositifs comme de Normandie dans
l'ancien par exemple puissent
s'appliquer ou puis se mobiliser dans le
cadre de programmes gouvernementaux bien
bien particulierers nous avons le zan
vous en avez parlé le zéro
artificialisation nette qui accentue
l'urgence de la
réhabilitation du bâti ancien et le
levier de la construction nouvelle que
nous avons pu parfois mobiliser dans une
grande proportion auparavant et bien on
ne peut désormais plus plus y avoir
recours et la dans la ruralité justement
qui disposera d'enveloppe de
construction plus limité dans dans
l'avenir et et on peut s'en satisfaire
sur un certain point et bien la
revitalisation des Bours elle doit être
une une priorité aussi la question que
que je voulais vous poser monsieur le
ministre c'est comment va-t-on faire
dans les territoires ruraux sans outils
d'accompagnement sans outils
d'incitation direct justement qui sont
apportés à ces territoires en déprises
qui n'auront peut-être plus l'occasion
de construire ou de se renouveler pour
aider justement les collectivités à
reconquérir leur habitats vacans leur
leur friche le coût des réhabilitations
rend souvent plus facile la réalisation
de lotissement on l'a fait hein la
consommation de terrain que nous
souhaitons économiser il faut donc
trouver les moyens d'accompagner ces
réhabilitations la transformation de nos
friches dans la ruralité donc ma
question concrète monsieur le ministre
c'est quels outils directs mettez-vous à
destination des élus locaux euh qui sont
très nombreux à vous écouter merci à
vous monsieur le ministre on va essayer
de tenir dans les 2 minutes pour poser
la question
je je partage totalement votre analyse
mais totalement euh nous n'avons pas
aujourd'hui les bons outils pour les
nouveaux enjeux on a fonctionné avec un
modèle économique et un modèle de
développement territorial pendant 7 ans
sur la base effectivement du pétrole pas
cher sur la base de la voiture sur la
base de la consommation foncière pour
aujourd'hui se dire qu'il faut remettre
en cause ce modèle de développement
territorial avec de nouveaux enjeux et
les nouveaux enjeux vous les avez très
bien exprimés je partage à 300 ce que
vous venez de dire et donc bah la loi
logement elle a vocation à inventer ces
outils là voilà c'est-à-dire maintenant
c'est comment on réussit à adapter ces
nouveaux outils il faut faire comme vous
l'avez dit non plus ce qui était facile
en terme de modèle économique
c'est-à-dire on met un une zone
pavionnaire sur un champ de betterave
qui en terme d'ingénierie en terme
économique était particulièrement adapté
à maintenant tout ce que vous avez
évoqué sur la lutte contre la vacances
le recyclage les dents creuses les
friches et cetera et vous n'avez pas les
outils l'ingénierie il y a un début avec
France pluralité qui existe il faudra
sans doute renforcer il faudra renforcer
sans doute ces outils d'ingéerie demain
mobiliser peut-être les établissements
publics fonciers trouver de nouveaux
moyens d'intervention effectivement sur
sur ces territoires ruraux les petite
ville également mais je partage
complètement et donc quand je parlais
tout à l'heure de de cette loi logement
qui doit arriver c'est bien ça que je
voulais évoquer exactement ce que vous
avez dit c'està dire comment on arrive à
construire ces nouveaux outils il s'agit
pas en fait d' opposer les métropoles à
la ruralité il s'agit pas d'opposer les
grandes villes aux petites villes c'est
aujourd'hui de se dire qu'il faudra des
outils différents il y aura des outils
différents ce qu'on a pas pensé jusqu'à
présent en fait il y avait une unicité
des des outils de la politique du lement
et donc maintenant effectivement il faut
que dans ces territoir là on est aussi
des outils à la fois financiers à la
fois d'ingénierie qui doivent permettre
de de répondre à ces problèmes là donc
je partage totalement votre analyse et
c'est bien le but du jeu de les inventer
lesquels et ben on va concerter pendant
6 mois pour trouver comment il faut le
faire j'eni j'en ai dit quelques-uns je
pense que notamment les établissements
publics fonciers doivent être très
fortement renforcés et notamment pour ce
type de travaill là merci alors en 2
minutes Yve bleuven
oui ben ça va un peu dans dans ce
sens-là vous avez parlé d'outils vous
avez parlé de territorialisation euh ce
qu'on constate depuis quelques années
c'est que le monde économique les
entreprises s'intéressent de plus en
plus à la problématique du logement
parce que pour pouvoir embaucher il faut
des solutions de logement euh sur le 1 %
logement collecté par Action Logement
est centralisé depuis des années il y a
une vraie opacité de la redistribution
quand on demande à Action Logement où
retourneent ces moyens à part nous
expliquer que il les mettent sur des
moyens importants notamment sur la
requalification urbaine et cetera on
constate que les territoires ruraux sont
complètement oubliés dans le retour sur
investissement et en tout cas les
entreprises commencent à fortement
raller et je p pense qu'il est important
qu'on
territorialise ce fameux C cette
cotisation du du de l'action logement et
qu'on ait une vision claire sur les
territoires de où est-ce qu'elle revient
le deuxième élément c'est que en 2008
vous avez parlé de de des opérations qui
avaient été mis en place pour déstocker
les VEFA avaient permis de déstocker
vous avez parlé du logement locatif
intermédiaire il serait pas judicieux de
regarder vous parlez beaucoup de de
boîes à outil si si on ne peut pas
trouver des solutions là encore avec les
entreprises en couplant un démembrement
de ces stocks restants en jouant sur la
nu propriété que pourraient acheter les
entreprises seul ou à plusieurs en les
mettant en gestion au bailleur pour
retrouver des solutions auprès de leurs
salariés des solutions de logement je
pense qu'on a besoin d'être imaginatif
innovant en matière d'outil et
saisissons cette chance que aujourd'hui
les entre sont prêtes à investir avec
nous collectivité sur cette
problématique du
logement oui
oui sur la question du de la
[Musique]
PEC je me méfie
toujours je me méfie toujours quand on
quand on touche au paritarisme et à la
gestion par je suis plutôt paritariste
dans l'â et euh je trouve que c'est pas
plus mal euh moi j'ai beaucoup milité
parce que je je comprends vous n'êtes
pas le le premier à à me dire ce
sentiment de pas avoir le retour sur le
territoire de de la
PEC je je privilégie la l'écriture de
convention territorialisé euh je l'ai
annoncé au au au congrès de de Nantes
pour deux raisons d'abord parce qu'on
voulait me faire donner un objectif de
production à l'échelle nationale qui
pour moi n'avait pas beaucoup de sens et
donc je voulais des objectifs de
production de logement sociaux à
l'échelle territoriale et puis aussi
parce que justement ça peut renforcer
des conventions territoriales entre
Action Logement les collectivités et et
l'État mais en particulier entre Action
Logement et les
collectivités sur sur sur mon territoire
de la Communauté urbaine de nakerque par
exemple nous signons en ce moment une
convention avec Action Logement qui a
été lancée avant que je devienne
ministre je précise les choses et je
pense que ces solutions là doivent
permettre de donner du contenu
territorialisé à la PEC et donc
aujourd'hui je vais commencer à Dijon
cette semaine je vais je vais à Dijon la
le 9 pour commencer à signer ces
conventions territorialisées et je pense
que ces conventions sont l'occasion de
pour Action Logement de décliner
justement sur les territoires donc
forcément ce sera à l'échelle de de
l'équivalent d'e na donc est plutôt une
intercommunalité ou un bassin de vie de
décliner effectivement l'intervention
d'actiontion logement et donc
concrètement de la PEC sur le territoire
en
question le le Action Logement aussi
développe aussi un programme à
destination des saisonniers vous savez
que visal a été élargi au saisonniers
donc effectivement il y a une volonté
d'aller agir sur sur ces territoire là
donc pour répondre directement à votre
question la solution aujourd'hui que je
je préconise et que je poursuis c'est
l'idée de convention territorialisé
entre Action Logement et les territoires
pour donner du contenu territorial
plutôt qu'un éclatement j'ai envie de
dire de la PEC par
territoire sur la question de la de la
la nu propriété qui pourrait être pris
par les entreprises prise euh c'est des
réflexions qui sont effectivement en
cours il y a également des députés qui
sont mobilisés donc je pense notamment
au député Da Silva qui est mobiliser sur
cette question également moi je suis
tout à fait favorable à des réflexions
qui pourraient permettre de renforcer
l'engagement des entreprises au-delà de
la PEC faut pas forcément que ça se
fasse au détriment de la PEC parce que
sinon ce qu'on met d'un côté on risque
de le perdre de l'autre à mon avis mais
en tout cas pourquoi pas après la
question démembrement est aussi une très
bonne question moi je trouve que le BRS
une très bonne chose j'aurais même voulu
aller plus loin j'avais fait des
propositions d'innovation financière
pour pour le financement de de
l'accession à la propriété en jouant sur
le distingo nu propriété et foncier je
pense que c'est une piste d'avenir et on
peut travailler alors en plus si les
entreprises ont envie de de se
positionner là-dessus il y a à mon avis
des choses à faire je suis assez
d'accord avec vous là-dessus à
travailler effectivement Sylvian Noël
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre vous avez évoqué dans vos
propos les enjeux de transition
énergétique du parc de logement c'est
sur ce point que je souhaitais vous
interroger puisque le nouveau DPE issu
de la loi climat et résilience vise à à
comment dire à exclure du parc locatif
de nombreux appartements jugés énergivor
à partir de 2025 or ce nouveau DPE
pénalise gravement les logements ancien
chauffé à l'électricité puisqu'il
multiplie par un facteur de 2,3 la
consommation réelle des logements
affiché au compteur tandis que les
autres énergies comme le Fule ou le gaz
euh non'ont ne sont infligés d'aucune
pénalité alors qu'elles émettent
d'importantes quantités de gaz à effet
de serre cette pénalité infligé au
logement chauffé à l'électricité semble
d'autant plus incohérente qu'elle que
que 90 % de notre production électrique
est décarboné et malgré cela et bien un
logement chauffé au gaz aura une
meilleure note au DPE qu'un logement
chauffé à l'électricité et donc on
risque de se retrouver avec un grand
nombre de logements chauffés à
l'électricité et exclu du parc locatif
d'ici 2025 et cela risque d'aggraver
grandement la crise que nous vivons donc
je voulais connaître un petit peu votre
avis sur cette question et savoir si
vous envisagiez une évolution sur ce
point merci
eu du coup j'en profite et je je parle
je je vais vous parler des passeoirs
thermiques qui ne sont pas exclus du
parc locatif en 2025 qui tomberont sur
le critère de la de la dessence ou
plutôt de l'indessence euh à la
relocation à partir de 2025 ce qui
donnera effectivement la possibilité au
locataires d'attaquer le propriétaire en
justice au titre de la descence donc on
est loin de l'interdiction on est loin
de l'interdiction d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
au moment au moment où on parle à peu
près 140000 logements sont en G+ et
continuent à être
loué alors que depuis 2023 ils sont
exclus du parc locatif selon votre
définition du mot du mot exclusion donc
je pense qu'il faut bien comprendre le
mécanisme et et et il est assez subtile
je veux nuancer ce proposl je dis pas
mais on parle voilà c'est c'est c'est
une question d'évolution du critère de
la nacence aujourd'hui quand on regarde
G+ et G on parle de
673000 logements donc
673000 logements du parc locatif privé
aujourd'hui sont donc en G+ j'ai évoqué
les 140000 tout à l'heure ou ou en G
euh on a voulu faire donc j'ai tout de
suite était dès que j'ai été ministre
j'ai été sollicité sur un calendrier
intenable sur le DPE et cetera sur
d'abord le calendrier avant de répondre
directement à votre question sur le
calendrier j'ai donc voulu savoir si
effectivement il y avait une
impossibilité matérielle de faire les
travaux dans le délai imparti sachant
qu'en plus c'est à la relocation après
le prier jeien 2025 aujourd'hui les
professionnels semble m'indiquer que 90
% de ces logements en fait pourraient
atteindre le niveau dpef au 1er janvier
2025 c'est ce que me disent aujourd'hui
les
professionnels c'est-à-dire que qu'il
n'y a pas forcément besoin de travaux de
copropriété pour passer de géant F au
1er janvier 2025 et en plus on m'a donné
d'ailleurs le montant moyen de
l'investissement qui correspond et
honnêtement il est pas totalement
infaisable donc aujourd'hui au moment où
je vous parle on est en train de
continuer à regarder les choses on est
en train de réfléchir à un dispositif
qui sera ultra renforcé d'accompagnement
des propriétaires bailleurs donc
pourquoi pas un ma prime Renov Plus+
plus un accompagnateur Plus+ plus j'ai
envie de dire voir une priorisation dans
ma Prim Renov de quelqu'un qui dira
voilà je suis propriétaire bayur anger
il est traité de manière prioritaire
et mais l'objectif c'est effectivement
d'essayer
d'atteindre l'objectif de ces 90 % des
673000 logements qui basculent au moins
en F au 1ier je janvier 2025 pour le
passage de F en e c'est 2028 ce qui
laisse le temps de faire des travaux de
copropriété et nous travaillons en ce
moment à la à la création notamment ça
sera dans le projet de loi copropriété à
des
prêcopro à des dispositifs qui pourront
permettre au compropriétés une
simplification des procédures et un
accompagnement en termes financiers de
des ces travaux de copropriété pour
essayer d'atteindre les objectifs de la
transition écologique donc d'abord avant
d'arriver sur le DPE mon objectif c'est
d'abord d'essayer d'atteindre l'objectif
de la transition écologique c'est la
première priorité euh comme je dis
toujours la transition écologique c'est
pas une option il faut qu'on qu'on
l'atteigne et je pense que le risque de
déplacer le calendrier du 1er janvier
2025 au 1er juillet 2028 c'est qu'on se
retrouve tous ensemble ici à la fin de
l'année 2026 à dire exactement la même
chose et donc effectivement je pense
qu'il y a une pression à garder sur les
propriétaires bailleurs je suis
conscient qu'aujourd'hui
l'investissement locatif doit plutôt
être favorisé mais je pense qu'il faut
garder aujourd'hui cette pression sinon
ça ne se fera ça ne se fera jamais sur
votre question spécifique au DPE ce
qu'on a noter aujourd'hui c'est
qu'effectivement le le le mécanisme de
d'arriver au résultats du DPE semble
donner des résultats insatisfaisants
pour les petits logements sur donc
aujourd'hui effectivement sur la
question des petits logements nous
sommes en train de regarder entre
guillemets le logiciel si vous me
permettez l'expression pour
effectivement revoir peut-être la copie
du DPE sur les petits logements sur la
sur le reste nous souhaitons pas revenir
sur le
sujet il y a y a une multiplicité de
choses qui sont mises en avant j'ai
entendu cette question sur sur
l'électricité et
mais je pense qu'à un moment donné à
pardon à force de de vouloir changer le
thermomètre on sait plus forcément où on
est donc j'avoue que sur la question des
petits logements il y a quelque chose
qui dysfonctionne je pense que sur le
reste le but du jeu est pas de changer
la règle du jeu en tout cas aussi près
du de la date limite et des dates
limites qui arrivent donc je pense que
voilà en tout cas le le l'objectif
gouvernemental petite surface oui on est
en train de regarder au-delà des petites
surfaces on
euh moins moins de 40 moins de 40 m² et
si je peux me permettre monsieur le le
ministre sur la réforme du mode du
calcul du DPE il a effectivement corrigé
le biaet des petites surfaces mais il y
a aussi prendre en compte la la note sur
le confort d'été aujourd'hui le confort
d'été complètement absent du calcul et
demain nos concitoyens auront peut-être
plus à souffrir de la chaleur que du
froid et donc ça aussi c'est un
paramètre qu'il faut intégrer tout comme
dans la commission d'enquête que j'avais
présidé il y a aussi la question de
l'impensée du bâti ancien d'avant 1948
sur lequel effectivement on peut pas
agir de la même façon en particulier
quand on pense à l'isolation par
l'extérieur par exemple alors Philippe
brovalet ah bon d'accord alors on passe
à Amel gaker quelqu'un qui est de votre
département de de notre région pas de
département mais nous sommes voisins et
avec et avec plaisir de de nous sommes
même plus que ça puisque nous sommes
cocarnavaleux j'allais le dire non c'est
pas vrai mais c'est vrai en tout cas
merci Monsieur le Ministre deux sujets
que je souhaiterit aborder je reviens
rapidement sur le sujet du PTZ du pré
zéro vous proposez en fait de proroger
ce dispositif de 4 ans dispositif je le
rappelle c'est important réservé au
ménages les plus modestes et qui permet
de financer généralement la première
accession à la propriété vous proposez
également de le recentrer puisque seront
exclus les logements collectifs dans les
zones tendues et les maisons
individuelles et c'est sur ce point que
je souhaite en fait réagir alors ce
n'est pas une question piège je préfère
le dire aussi clairement ça veut dire
que c'est un peu ma question le modèle
le rêve du de beaucoup de Français de de
la petite maison avec le petit jardin
parce que j'entends peut-être ce que
vous allez évoquer comme comme argument
est définitivement enterré un de vos
prédécesseurs l'avait annoncé peut-être
prématurément ce qui avait provoqué je
me souviens pas mal de de réactions
alors quand je vous dis c'est pas une
question de piège c'est que j'ai compris
que vous vouliez dire les les choses
clairement euh est-ce que vous confirmez
cette orientation et et est-ce que ce
modèle aujourd'hui doit être vraiment
abandonné particulièrement pour les
familles ou pour les Français modestes
ça c'est ma première question puis autre
sujet celui du logement étudiant je sais
que c'est un sujet qui vous tient qui
vous tient à cœur dans le marché
immobilier tendu que nous connaissons
les étudiants sont peut-être les les les
plus touchés le déséquilibre entre
l'offre la demande est très très
important et en septembre 2023 vous avez
tous tous ces chiffres là ce sont près
de 3 millions d'étudiants qui étaient
présents qui ont fait le rentrée 15000
de plus qu'en 2022 heureusement les
résidences étudiantes ont un peu ou
atténu un peu ce déséquilibre l'offre
des CROUS c'est un élément aussi
important pour les étudiants boursiers
aujourd'hui n'accueille qu'un quart de
la population boursière bref aujourd'hui
des étudiants arrêtent leurs études
parce qu'il ne peuvent pas se loger on
voit même une catégorie d'étudiants SDF
c'est-à-dire des des étudiants qui
pendant toute leur année scolaire
cherchent des bons plans euh toute
l'année pour pouvoir poursuivre leurs
études donc encore une fois je le dis
hein je sais que vous y êtes attentif
mais ma question est simple quelle
mesure choc souhaitez-vous proposer pour
véritablement en tout cas apporter des
réponses à court terme sur cette
difficulté merci mercici euh alors sur
le prê à taux
zéro d'abord le
distingo zone tendue zone détendu sur
versus ancien rénové je pense que ça
rejoint ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
ça doit faire partie et et renforcer du
coup ça doit faire partie de ces outils
qui doit s'adapter se différencier
suivant la réalité du territoire donc je
j'assume
parfaitement après il a été
rajouté des éléments sur la forme
ben bon
contactilà il a été rajouté des éléments
sur la forme urbaine j'habite dans une
maison individuelle dans la zone la plus
dense de l'agglomération d'un
carquoise voilà voilà sur le logement
étudiant sur le logement étudiant
euh vous m'avez compris
euh alors je je je suis euh alors
peut-être parce que ça me touche aussi
personnellement
euh je ne veux pas accepter que on me
donne le chffre de 12 % je sais pas d'où
il vient mais ça a été mis dans un dans
un journal que 12 % effectivement des
des étudiants renonceraient à leurs
études ou changeraient le leurs études
pour des questions liées logement moi ce
ce chiffre ne ne me va pas vous le savez
et et dès mon arrivée j'ai souhaité
vraiment prendre un BC cette question
alors quand on est ministre du Logement
il faut pas être enfin il faut avoir une
certaine dose d'abnégation parce qu'on
sait qu'on travaille pendant 2 ans ou 3
ans enfin bon c'est le voilà c'est c'est
la richesse du du du la fonction qui
fait que de toute façon la construction
néanmoins il faut l'engager et je pense
que ce plan logement étudiant j'ai j'ai
vraiment beaucoup je me suis beaucoup
mobilisé pour qu'il puisse avoir lieu je
pense qu'il est totalement saisi par la
première ministre saisi par ma collègue
Sylvie retaillot et aujourd'hui vraiment
on est en posture de combat donc
évidemment il faut à la fois produire du
logement social étudiant je pense que
nous avons beaucoup de capacités de
foncier universitaire j'y crois beaucoup
je pense qu'il faut sans doute revoir
des règles c'est tout simple parce que
la foncier universitaire c'est très
compliqué c'est très compliqué il y a
des procédures extrêmement complexes on
évoquait encore il y a pas très
longtemps une tour au milieu de
Strasbourg totalement vide parce qu'on
arrive pas à monter l'opération elle est
vide depuis 10 ans elle pourrait faire
du logement étudiant donc il y a des
problèmes de complexité des montages de
complexité foncière et cetera donc il
faut qu'on on arrive à simplifier tout
ça aujourd'hui il faut qu'on mette des
opérateurs performants et compétents sur
le sujet et on doit pouvoir développer
davantage de de logement étudiant
logement social étudiant dans dans les
années qui viennent en tout cas c'est
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment mon
souhait et puis comme je le disais tout
à l'heure il y a d'autres pistes il y a
des agglomérations qui ont connu des
très grands logements mais qui n'ont
plus forcément de très grandes familles
une intermédiation avec on a notamment
pris contact avec la fève là-dessus pour
pouvoir organiser des colollocations
étudiantes c'est faisable de la
diversification dans le cadre de l'EN
rue moi je vois des projets en rue où on
veut diversifier on parle de
diversification et ben s'il faut
diversifier pourquoi pas dans des
projets en rue je pense notamment à
l'île-de-fance à chaque fois d'une
diversification par des logements
étudiants ou par des résidences seiores
d'ailleurs c'est un objet de
diversification de de qui serait très
utile dans le cadre de la politique de
la ville et je suis certain que beaucoup
de de d'étudiants accepteraient
justement d'apporter ces éléments
diversification de peuplement dans ces
quartiers où on en a besoin où on a
besoin de retrouver de la mixité sociale
donc la diversification dans les projets
en rue euh la transformation de bureau
en logement il y a notamment un outil
d'action logement qui qui vise à
accélérer le travail sur cette
transformation de bureau en logement moi
je crois beaucoup en ça il y a l'idée
aussi dans le lli d'ouvrir le lli à de
la résidence euh à de la résidence lli
donc pourquoi pas de la résidence
étudiante lli donc on est en train donc
dans le plan étudiant logement étudiant
qu'on est en train d'essayer d'élaborer
donc avec ma collègue Sylvie retaillot
et avec la première ministre il y a
toute une série de mesures qu'on est en
train d'explorer mais oui il faut il
faut y répondre et et je partage
totalement le besoin aujourd'hui donc on
s'y attelle et on revient le plus
rapidement vers vous avec un certain
nombre de de mesures à proposer et le
logement temporaire via des
containers euh oui il a il y a des idées
il y a même des idées de comment de Tiny
house dit pour pour les étudiants euh
voilà tiny
house voilà euh enfin moi les tin j'ai
du mal moi je sais pas pourquoi
je mais oui il y a des idées de de
logement temporaires c'est des choses
qu'on peut explorer Bernard
buit merci présidente rapidement une
question sur la régulation des
compléments de loyer le complément de
loyer correspond au montant additionnel
d'un locataire s'acquit en plus de son
loyer au titre d'une ou plusieurs
caractér exceptionnel de localisation ou
de confort de son logement si ces
compléments de loyer ne sont applicables
que dans certaines grandes villes et
dans certaines conditions la la
régulation actuelle des compléments de
loyer est-elle suffisante et comment
peut-on
l'améliorer beaucoup beaucoup même
d'association de locataire m'évoquent
les abus sur les les compléments de
loyer aujourd'hui il y aura sans doute
besoin de réguler surtout d'en donner
une inition plus précise et je pense que
c'est comme ça qu'on peut qu'on peut
résoudre le
problème mais j'ai envie de je trouve
que ça pose
un un autre
débat que j'évoque depuis le le début et
et qui doit à mon avis faire l'objet de
notre réflexion
collective on veut en même temps
soutenir et développer l'investissement
locatif par le
particulier et en même temps euh on a la
question de la transition écologique et
donc du DP
euh on a on a des questions
de de loyer de complément de de loyer
certains évoquent même l'idée
de comment dire comment ça s'appelle
pour les voitures de contrôle technique
des
logements en fait je pense que ce qu'on
a à trouver c'est le juste équilibre
entre quelque chose qui doit permettre
quand même à un certain nombre de nos
concitoyens de vouloir investir dans
l'investissement locatif de vouloir
détenir du parc locatif privé
et et en même temps un certain nombre de
contraintes qui paraissent minimales et
donc notamment la définition du du
complément de loyer et ce donc il faut
trouver le juste équilibre entre des
choses qui ne soient pas trop complexes
considéré comme de trop grosses
contraintes pour finalement ne pas
décourager l'investissement locatif
parce qu'on a besoin du particulier
aujourd'hui on a besoin de parc locatif
privé et les institutionnels ne
remplaceront pas les particuliers on est
en train de travailler pour augmenter
mais ça remplacera pas donc il nous faut
des investisseurs particuliers donc à la
fois il faut des choses qui soient
suffisamment incitatives et et pas trop
contraignantes et en même temps on a des
exigences de transition écologique de de
de définition des loyers de voilà donc
voilà c'est une réflexion collective
qu'on doit avoir finalement c'est
comment on arrive à quand même avoir des
investisseurs particuliers qui font qui
font de la location et en même temps euh
et en même temps exiger un certain
nombre de contraintes qui sont
totalement légitimes au regard des des
enjeux futurs voilà donc c'est c'est une
vraie question de fond Vivian Artigalas
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre moi je voulais vous
interroger sur le problème de l'accès au
logement qui est devenu un réel problème
cet accès au logement euh à la fois pour
les propriétaires pour comme
propriétaire mais aussi comme comme
locataire et ce problème concerne
maintenant tous les territoires y
compris les territoires ruraux et pas
seulement les zones tendues euh les
causes en sont multiples vous l'avez
évoqué mais je vais moi sur deux de ces
causes la première enfin souligner deux
de ces causes le coût du foncier le
premier vous l'avez dit nous sommes très
en attente d'outils de régulation du
foncier il faut s'y atteler très très
rapidement les maires les bailleurs les
les promoteurs tout le monde attend
vraiment ce coup de foncier c'est
peut-être et la loisane n'arrange rien à
ce sujet le deuxème sujet c'est sur la
la fiscalité locative bon qui est très
défavorable vous le savez au profit des
meublés touristiques pour les au et au
détrriment des logements à l'année alors
que le le nombre de logements de
résidences louées sur les plateformes
explose chaque amenée au détriment du
marché locatif transaditionnel les
ajustements que vous proposez dans le
PLF 2024 ne permettront pas d'inverser
la tendance d'autant plus que ces
mesures ne concernent je le dis encore
que les zones tendues euh pourquoi alors
qu'il y a urgence attendre 2025 c'est ce
que vous annoncez pour cette réforme de
la fiscalité locative alors que des
propositions existent déjà à l'Assemblée
nationale sur ce sujet et puis vous avez
parlé aussi de de de d'un outil de
régulation des meublés touristique
euh euh c'est important pour tous les
territoires euh pourquoi ne pas élargir
rapidement le décret zone touristique
tendue mais sans appliquer la méthode
Édon qui Ava été choisi pour le premier
élargissement qui donne des résultats
parfois très surprenants et j'en ai
quelques exemples sur mon
territoire le territoire des Hautes
Pyrénées sur les outils de régulation du
foncier je je me suis dà exprimé je
partage effectivement c'est c'est des
choses qu'il faut qu'il faut inventer je
parlais de la loi logement tout à
l'heure c'est là qu'il faudra inventer
ces nouveaux outils on n même pas
aujourd'hui au niveau des collectivités
un droit de préhemption pour lutte
contre la spéculation foncière donc déjà
on va commencer par ça et puis puis mais
je pense qu'il y a d'autres outils à
avoir parce qu'il y a aussi une question
financière vous le disiez tout à l'heure
monsieur le sénateur il y a aussi une
question financière derrière quand on
intervient dans la ruralité on n pas
forcément les moyens de pouvoir
investirement donc il y a aussi des
questions financières derrière donc je
partage là-dessus on aura l'occasion de
revenir sur les meublet touristique je
vais préciser ce que ce que je voulais
dire tout à
l'heure il y a deux questions il y a une
question de la fiscalité des meublés
touristiques et il y a une question de
la régulation par la commune du
développement des meublés
touristiques je pense
que parmi ces deux solutions la plus
urgente est la deuxè c'està-dire avoir à
disposition un outil de
régulation parce que du coup les
communes qui sont en difficulté qui voi
se
développer j'en suis le témoin qui voit
se développer à une vitesse grandv les
meubl touristiqu on le moyen par exemple
de fixer des quotas voir d'interdire le
développement de nouveau si on met en
place le système de la compensation
aujourd'hui mais si on va demain avec un
nouvel outil on pourra arrêter le
développement c'est voilà il y aura plus
la possibilité de faire moi je voudrais
aller jusque là c'estàd je voudrais
aller jusqu'à ce que les communes qui le
souhaitent arrêtent interdisent
clairement le développement des be
touristiques et là du coup ça STO le
phénomène on a un système de régulation
du marché des bubl touristiques et ce
saise de l'outil les communes qui ont
envie de s'en saisir donc ça pour moi
c'est la priorité c'est le de la
proposition de loi Le Meur et chanise
qui doit arriver en décembre à
l'Assemblée nationale donc au prier
trimestre 2024 chez vous pour
probablement une CMP aux alentours du
mois de mars et donc théoriquement au
mois de mars 2024 si tout va bien on a
cet outil de régulation à la disposition
des communes si tout va
bien partoutout partout partout toutes
les communes à la discrétion des
communes ceux qui n'en veulent pas ils
le font pas voilà à discrétion
ça c'est la première chose c'est c'est
la question des outils de régulation
d'ailleurs au passage tout à l'heure on
parlait de la loi logement et de la
décentralisation de la politique du
logement c'est pas que des compétences
la politique du logement c'est aussi des
outils de régulation des outils de
réglementation et donc ça là pour moi
c'est un outil de réglementation et
après il y a la question de la fiscalité
qui est une deuxème question je pense
qu'à partir du momentù on aura l'outil
de régulation la question dealité va
être Mo urgente et va pouvoir on va
pouvoir le le poser pour moi c'est une
question plus de justice fiscale en
réalité j'ai envie de dire quelque part
je vous renvoie la question est-ce qu'il
est légitime que quelqu'un qui loue un
meublé est une une aide public entre
guillemets plus importante que celui qui
loue en location nu c'est une question
de justice
fiscale j'ai envie de dire c'est c'est
vous en tant que parlementaire qui
pouvez encore plus facilement que moi
répondre à cette question est-ce que
vous trouvez ça juste si vous trouvez ça
injuste et ben effectivement sans doute
que la mission parlementaire qui est
confié sur la la réforme de la fisc
fiscalité locative et puis les occasions
que vous aurez pour revenir sur cette
question de la fiscalité locative vous
donneront la question d'avoir
effectivement une fiscalité juste moi je
me suis déjà exprimé sur la question
dans dans dans un quotidien national
donc vous connaissez ma position je vais
arrêter d'insister voilà donc vous
connaissez déjà ma position en terme de
justice fiscale mais voilà j'ai envie de
dire que euh pour moi c'est c'est plus
cette question là qui doit qui doit
permettre de définir le bon niveau de
fiscalité ou pas à la fois on doit pas
décourager les investisseurs c'est ce
que j'évoqué tout à l'heure à la fois il
faut qu'on encourage l'investissement
locatif demain parce qu'on a besoin des
particuliers qui louent dans le privé
donc la fiscalité est l'un des outils
c'est ben un super outils et de l'autre
côté on doit pouvoir réguler un certain
nombre de de marchés aujourd'hui quand
il quand il génère une attrition de
logement et en tout cas quelque chose
qui empêche les étudiants les
saisonniers voir
les un certain nombre de de de résidents
du territoire d'accéder au logement
partage totalement votre analyse et
intégrer les logements en touristique
dans le le calendrier de la loi climat
et résilience aujourd'hui ils échappent
donc voilà ils sont pas concernés même
s'ils sont étiquetés Foug alors c'est
dans la loi c'est dans le la proposition
de loi excusez-moi Le Meur et chanise
alors par contre je vous
alerte on n toujours pas trouvé comment
on
fait donc on est en train d'accompagner
les les deux députés je vous explique
pourquoi c'est le principe de la
naissance euh un DPE demain un DPE g il
y a le locataire qui va attaquer en
justice le locataire d'un BNB pardon
d'un meublet
touristique ne va sans doute pas
attaquer en
justice et donc parce que il va passer
une nuit et il va pas s'embêter avec une
procédure de justice face au
propriétaire donc le système qui est mis
en place pour euh la location longue
durée ne fonctionnera pas pour euh les
meublés touristiqu et donc il faut qu'on
invente un autre système alors peut-être
justement avec l'outil de régulation de
la commune peut-être que la commune qui
de qui qui par exemple met en place un
système d'agrément peut demander
peut-être le DPE et donc le refuser à ce
titre
mais du coup ça voudrait dire que ce
soit pas appliqué de la même manière sur
le territoire national oui et on tombe
sur un problème juridique donc pour
l'instant on n' pas encore la solution
pour pour en fait la solution juridique
qui permet de d'aligner en fait les
meublés
touristiques sur la location longue
durée donc il faut l'avoir en tête il y
a un problème juridique il y a un
problème juridique ok Rémy
Cardon merci madame la Présidente
figurez-vous je vais rebondir sur vos
propos euh puisque c'était l'objet de ma
question sur le fait que j'ai suivi vos
différentes interviews sur le sujet où
vous êtes plutôt pour aligner la
fiscalité des mebliers touristiques avec
celle des meubliés traditionnel et et la
location vide également vous avez dit
aussi dans une autre interview que vous
fallait laisser la main au
parlementairirees quand je vous entends
effectivement vous vous conforte ces
propos et je pense que ça vous ça vous a
pas échappé mais il me semble qui avait
312 députés donc une majorité absolue à
l'Assemblée nationale qui a déposé un
amendement pour harmoniser la fiscalité
du marché locatif à un taux de 40 %
notamment sur les abotements fiscaux sur
les meublés touristiques et donc la
niche fiscale
Airbnb alors du coup étant doné qu'il y
a eu un quand même beaucoup de de
parlementaires il y a eu un amendement
mais il y a eu un 493 et là plus un
bruit de votre
part vous êtes rentré dans le rang et
vous avez là vous êtes en train de dire
que on va en parler en 2025 enfin en
tout cas voilà ma question elle est
simple euh comment expliquez-vous votre
impuissance monsieur le ministre non non
je je ne suis pas impuissant je ne suis
pas impuissant elle est elle est
tendancieuse cette
phrase
euh euh je je pense que la première
ministre a raison
euh effectivement il y avait à un moment
donné peut-être dans l'urgence la
précipitation on m'a demandé une
position j'ai livré ma position
personnelle mais j'ai toujours dit si
vous avez suivi mes interviews j'ai
toujours dit que l'outil de régulation
était plus urgent que la question de la
fiscalité je l'ai toujours dit j'ai
toujours dit ce qu'il fallait faire
d'abord c'est l'outil de régulation
collectivité parce que je pense que
c'est ça qui arrêtera le phénomène
aujourd'hui des meublés touristiqu sur
la f sur la question de la fiscalité
locative le problème c'est que en fait
il y a beaucoup de régimes
et et en fait il y a une grande
complexité derrière tout ça alors j'ai
donné ma position à un moment donné mais
il y a une grande complexité et je pense
que cette miss et puis derrière j'ai
évoqué il y a aussi la question de
l'incitation c'estàdire attention aussi
de ne pas j'ai envie de dire jeter le
béb avec le dubain et donc du coup se
retrouver avec plus d'investisseurs
particulierers qui veulent demain
continuer de de à faire du locatif privé
hein parce que là on a besoin du parc
privé locatif en France hein donc on a
besoin de gens qui qui soient des
bailleur on en a besoin et donc la
position de la premierre ministre a été
de de dire bah ok on fait l'outil donc
elle m'a aidé à effectivement à faire
inscrire dans la niche de décembre la
proposition de loi sur l'outil de
régulation et donc il a qui arrivera
dans le calédrier qui je l'espère ça
dépend de vous maintenant arrivera
j'espère au mois de mars pour les
collectivités et ensuite finalement se
donner cette mission parlementaire est
le temps d'une réflexion mais du coup
pour l'ensemble des régimes et pour la
question de l'ensemble des questions
c'est pas simplement la question de la
justice fiscale sur le meublet
touristique versus la location nu versus
le meublet mais tous les régimes il
compris en réel on pose tout sur la
table et on pose à la fois la question
de comment on motive des gens à
poursuivre de l'investissement locatif
là où on en a le plus besoin par exemple
pour la résidence longue durée estce que
c'est pas ça qu'on doit aider justement
plutôt que du meublet touristique en
tout cas voilà prenons le temps
d'examiner tous les effets de bord
prenons le temps d'examiner toutes les
conséquences en plus c'est important
l'alignement ça a généré des
conséquences très importantes he donc
prenons c'est quelques mois pour essayer
de se mettre d'accord mais sur tout
c'est faisons la réforme de la fiscalité
locgative mais sur tout pas sur un point
pas sur le meublet touristique sur
l'ensemble et voyons tous les effets de
bord et prenons le temps en attendant il
y aura un outil de régulation donc
théoriquement on doit calmer le jeu sur
les meublés touristiques à partir du
moment où on a l'outil de régulation et
derrière on on on se prend le temps de
regarder tous les régimes tous les
régimes de la fiscalité locative euh en
même temps Eveline corbnamazo on
verra on verra il peut y avoir des lois
de finances
rectificatives c'est bon pour Eveline
merci Monsieur le Ministre euh mon
intervention euh va porter sur euh sur
les le logement et spécifiquement le
logement à la Réunion
euh qui est le territoire
euh pour lequel je suis euh je suis élu
sénatrice donc simplement vous dire je
pense que vous connaissez la situation
du logement à la Réunion qui est euh
euh en crise on peut le dire donc euh
nous avons 41000 demandes de logement
euh en souffrance demandes de logement
sociaux 80 % concerernne des logements
sociaux ou très sociaux et euh nous nous
n'arrêtons ont pas de constater une une
diminution de production de ces
logements ces dernières
années il y a aussi la question de la
dessence autour de la production des
logements il y a aussi la question de la
dessence de ces logements puisque nous
avons 135 immeubles qui ont moins de 10
ans et qui sont aujourd'hui jugés
indécent pourquoi j'en parle parce que
effectivement à la Réunion donc nous
avons un clim tropical et donc nous
produision des logements qui répondent
aux normes
européennes ce qui fait que euh au bout
de 10 ans et bien les familles euh qui
donc vivent des minimas sociaux et des
aides
social se retrouent dans des logements
indécents avec des moisissures et cela
génère des problèmes de santé donc on a
le le pack entier c'est-à-dire minimas
sociaux logement indescent problèm de
santé et et donc c'est un engrenage
infernal dans lequel les familles
s'enfoncent donc ma question elle porte
vraiment
sur la logique de la politique de
logement qui est menée en outrem et
particulièrement à la Réunion il faut
savoir que
étant une île nous nous avons
effectivement comme ici mais de façon
beaucoup plus criante à la Réunion le
problème de la rareté du
foncier nous en sommes à devoir donc la
pression est importante puisqu'il faut
préserver les terres agricoles il y a le
développement économique il y a de gros
difficultés de déplacement et là-dessus
la question de production de logement
donc au regard de l'inflation et des
difficultés géographiques que nous
rencontrons
les logements sont de plus en plus
chers dans la dans les constructions et
cela a une répercussion immédiate sur le
coût des loyers donc nos logements
sociaux et très sociaux sont de plus en
plus chers de plus en plus indécents et
génère de plus en plus de
difficultés de problèmes sanitaires à
cela
s'ajoute un je l'ai déjà dit dans cette
commission une situation sociale qui est
aussi si inquiétante puisque 36 % de la
population vit en dessous du seuil de la
pauvreté je rappelle que le la moyenne
française est à 14 % donc et je
puisqueon parlait tout à l'heure des
enfants un enfant sur deux à la Réunion
vit en dessous du seuil de la pauvreté
donc tout ça pour dire
que c'est c'est là si on est vraiment
dans une crise du logement qui n'est pas
faite pour
s'arranger juste rappeler également que
nous sommes un des départ artement les
plus touchés par les violences faites
aux femmes 98 % des familles
monoparentales sont dirigées par des
femmes donc le dernier rapport qui a été
rendu par la Fondation Abé piierre
disait avait pour avait sous-titré son
rapport en disant en l'appelant le
mallogement des femmes donc c'est
vraiment un
sujet un sujet de Fond donc vous voyez
c'est c'est la le cumul de toutes ces
situations sociales des dégradé qui qui
qui font que le l'avenir est sombre pour
ces familles j'ajoute également que la
oui rapidement mais la loi Pinelle est
faite est prévue de s'arrêter en
2024 et que du coup ça n'est pas fait
pour arranger les choses puisque vous
disiez tout à l'heure qu'on misait sur
la production de logement privé à la
Réunion ça va être encore plus compliqué
nous avons aussi également constater que
comme partout les les banques reculent
sur la la l'acceptation de prês et donc
au niveau de du du problème du logement
à la réunion nous nous enfonçons voilà
monsieur le ministre vous avez une très
belle île euh et j'ai eu l'occasion d'y
aller parce que c'était l'un de mes
territoires de ma thèse et donc j'y ai
vu toutes les aberrations des
dispositifs d' fiscal à la Réunion où
des quincahers devenent du jour au
lendemain promoteur faisant des
logements de bien piètre qualité par
pour des métropolitains qui ne voyaient
que l'avantage fiscal qui n'avaient
jamais mis une seule fois les pieds à la
Réunion et probablement ont jamais mis
les pieds à la Réunion une fois dans
leur vie mais qui se prenaient à
davantage fiscal dans des logements
d'ailleurs qui au départ étaient vid qui
après avec la démographie ont finit par
se remplir et ce sont dégradés comme
vous l'avez décrit en moins de 10 ans
donc j'ai j'ai vu effectivement à la
réunion tout le mal que pouvait faire
aussi une aide fiscale quand elle était
pas régulée et pas contrôlée et je pense
que vous payez aussi quelque part donc
moi le Pinel qui s'en va pour la réunion
je suis pas certain que ce soit une
mauvaise nouvelle mais bon c'était une
c'était une
parenthèse mes collaborateurs me
passaient effectivement un certain
nombre de de de
d'éléments effectivement on est en train
de travailler sur sur la Réunion il y a
un travail sur les bailleurs sociaux
pour les consolider euh euh sur le plan
financier il y a Lana qui intervient de
plus en plus j'ai évoqué avec mon
directeur cabinet Arnaud Cursente
l'hypothèse aussi vous savez qu'on a un
programme territoire engagé pour le
logement c'est-à-dire sur un certain une
vingtaine de territoires une forme
d'accélération et essayer de travailler
une accélération la Réunion pourrait
très bien être un un site assez
emblématique pour essayer d'accélérer la
la production de logement et être l'un
de ces sites alors je peux pas
aujourd'hui m'avancer mais en tout cas
c'est une des réflexions en cours de l'
des territoires qui pourrait bénéficier
de cette accélération spécifique contenu
du du besoin que vous avez exprimé tout
à l'heure ce qu'on recherche en fait
c'est ces territoire où le besoin est
archi urgent et et vous en faites vous
en faites largement partie et puis
au-delà de ce que de ce que vous venez
de dire et finalement vous êtes
l'incarnation suprême du besoin de
différenciation de nos outils de la
politique du logement et vous l'avez dit
dans votre propos vous avez dit
finalement les normes nationales voilà
et je l'ai pas évoqué tout à l'heure
mais la question de l'adaptation des
normes non seulement elle est une
évidence pour nos territoires d'outrem
mais est-ce qu'elle n'est pas aussi
devenue une évidence pour notre
territoire métropolitain bien sr je dire
entre mon territoire d'unkerercois qui
va subir trois tempêtes en plus de 150
km/h vous avez une très belle
illustration en ce moment et le
territoire nimois qui va subir du plus
de 50 degrés est-ce que nous devons
avoir les mêmes normes de construction
c'est-à-dire que ce que l'outrem nous a
appris et qui a permis d'ailleurs de
différencier ma prime Renov suivant les
territoires ce que l'outreem nous
apprend est peut-être une leçon pour la
métropole et vous êtes peut-être en
train de nous donner des leçons sur
notre incapacité que nous avons sur le
territoire métropolitain à différencier
nos normes de construction ce qui arrive
en outremè peut nous arriver à nous
aussi si on n' pas cette capacité à
davantage différencier et la question
des normes de construction et peut-être
aussi sur la table de la loi logement
faut-il les mêmes normes de construction
à nîes à linkererque ou à Brest ce sont
des questions qui à mon avis sont sur la
table et et que vous posez à travers
votre votre témoignage donc pour
répondre sur la Réunion on regarde ça
avec attention voilà alors encore trois
questions et on va vous libérer monsieur
le ministre en vous remerciant pour vos
réponses très précis Daniel
Salm merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure des des logements sociaux et de
la rénovation qui a plutôt bien avancé
comme quoi les bailleurs sociaux
lorsqu'on leur laisse les moyens sont
capables de faire le travail aujourd'hui
c'est un peu plus un peu plus difficile
vous nous avez parlé de de fonds de
fonds pour les aider à la rénovation
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire un
peu plus sur le montant de ces fonds et
sous quelle forme ils vont être apportés
aux bailleurs sociaux sinon deè deuxème
élément vous nous avez dit que vous
alliez permettre l'ouverture au fonds
d'investissement ouvrir les logements
intermédiaires au fonds
d'investissement qui dit fond
d'investissement dit rendement vous le
savez quel rendement va est attendu par
ces fonds d'investissement et moi je me
pose la question de fond euh on parle
souvent de la valeur travail comment se
fait-il qu'aujourd'hui un couple
d'ouvriers ne puisse plus faire
construire comme il y a quelques
décennies et qu'on doit toujours avoir
recours à des fonds d'investissement
pour pouvoir faire les investissements
sur la construction neuve alors que
avant et bien des gens par leur travail
étaient en capacité d'investir et ils ne
le peuvent plus aujourd'hui donc il y a
un moment il y a a une question de la
valeur
travail alors le le le fond euh le fond
dédié à la rénovation énergétique pour
les bailleurs sociaux et donc un fond
d'1,2 milliards donc sur 3 ans donc on
aura 400 millions par an sur opération
sous forme de subvention voilà donc les
bailleurs sociaux n'auront qu'à qu'à
demander une subvention de de l'État au
titre de ce fond sur la question du
logement locatif
intermédiaire d'abord on on on je je
parle souvent des institutionnels parce
que on est passé de quasiment 30 % hein
de mémoire à 1 % aujourd'hui dans le
locatif privé vous inquiétez pas je
pense pas 30 secondes qu'on va revenir à
30 % donc c'est pour ça tout à l'heure
j'insiste beaucoup aussi sur le
particulier qui doit rester
l'investisseur locatif archidominant
néanmoins je trouve qu' 1 % c'est faible
et je trouve que par exemple des
supports comme l'assurance vie ou
l'éparne retraite c'est-à-dire des
supports longs et plutôt français hein
moi j'ai pas envie de faire venir dans
le logement des fonds d'investissement
américains comme ça s'est passé en
Allemagne et on a vu les conséquences
sur les loyers donc c'est pas le but du
jeu
mais des fonds d'épargne retraite ou des
fonds d'assurance vie c'est-à-dire des
fonds d'épargne à vocation plutôt longue
peuvent avoir aujourd'hui comme
l'immobilier de bureau va mal peut avoir
besoin dans ses actifs un certain nombre
d'immobiliers résidentiels et donc
pourquoi pas c'est dire bon et en tout
cas pourquoi pas remoner de remonter de
3 4 % enfin voilà on en est là hein je
veux dire on est on n pas non plus je je
n'attends pas demain à ce que sur le
locatif privé on est on est des fonds de
pension je m'attends pas du tout à ça et
c'est pas le but du jeu euh mais si on
peut ne serait-ce que faire quelques
milliers de logements grâce à
l'assurance vie ou l'épne de retraite
pourquoi pourquoi s'en priver
euh euh alors la question que vous
posez elle me gêne un peu parce que
j'ai commencé par dire on doit inventer
le modèle de demain donc je je vous
dites pourquoi pas comme avant un couple
d'ouvriers pourrait faire cons en fait
ça ça repose sur la question du modèle
économique d'avant le modèle économique
d'avant c'était quoi c'était je vais
construire une maison sur un champ de
betterave donc le modèle économique
était très pertinent le pétrole était
pas cher donc j'acheté une voiture
d'ailleurs au passage ça transfère à
l'ouvrier l'achat de sa voiture et puis
le carburant qu'on met dedans ce qui est
pas pareil que le transport collectif
qui est pas payé par l'ouvrier oui voilà
non mais c'est ce que je disais
c'estàdire que le le le modèle
économique d'avant il était fondé sur
une énergie pas
chère et il a rendu des des millions de
Français dépendant de la voiture et donc
du prix du carburant à 50 voire 100 km
de leur
emploi et c'est ce modèle là aujourd'hui
qui est en crise et qu'
aujourd'hui vous irez sans doute au
petit bistr d'en face vous serez servi
par un serveur qui vit probablement à 1
heure de son
travail je pense que la question
centrale aujourd'hui c'est ça c'est
l'éloignement d'une partie de nos
populations de leur emploi est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est acceptable qu'une
caissière de supermarché qui nous sert
se retrouve à 50 ou 70 km de son travail
et mettre 1 heure pour accéder à son
travail est-ce qu'un salarié de la
restauration aujourd'hui qui a des
pauses entre 15h et 17h30 doit vivre à
100 km son
travail le problème d'aujourd'hui il est
là et c'est le modèle d'avant qui nous a
mis là et donc ce qu'il faut c'est ce
qu'il faut c'est réinventer ce nouveau
modèle et effectivement permettre à
laavur travail que je partage avec vous
vraiment permettre à cette valeur de
travail de trouver des réponses en lien
avec l'emploi la question aujourd'hui
qui est posée c'est pas est-ce que le
serveur du petit bistron en face il peut
accéder à la propriété c'est est-ce
qu'il peut avoir un logement est-ce
qu'il peut avoir un logement proche de
son emploi et la réponse est NON et donc
c'est pour ça que quand je dis les
outils qu'on a réinventer c'est sans
doute pas les outils d'avant mais c'est
comment on réussi à concilier le lien
emploi logement c'est l'un des défis il
y a la transition écologique il y a le
vieillissement il y a le lien emploi
logement et et et et cette question là à
mon avis elle est centrale et là pareil
on n pas les outils alors quand on parle
aujourd'hui du logement social par
exemple moi je vous dis mon sentiment je
trouve que le logement social dans le
modèle généraliste il permettrait de
faire la place à ces travailleurs clés
aujourd'hui si on se fixait l'objectif
de mixité sociale c'està dire si on
dédit le logement social à un équilibre
entre les travailleurs clés et les
personnes les plus démunies on aurait à
la fois la mixité et à la fois la
réponse à cette question bah c'est des
débats qu'on aura peut-être ensemble
dans le cadre de la loi logement mais
voilà en tout cas cette question du
rapprochement et du lien emploi logement
me semble être une question essentielle
de l'avenir de la politique du logement
et en tout cas l'un des sujets qu'on
aura à poser dans la future l' logement
Anne Catherine Loisier et ensuite
frédérical merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre alors en fait c'est
une demande de précision par rapport à à
la question que vient d'aborder mon mon
collègue sur la construction de de
logements sociaux par les bailleurs donc
et pour revenir au au PLF donc là
j'entends qu'il y aurait donc une une
enveloppe de 400 millions ça j'ai bien
entendu par an donc qui serait destiné
essentiellement à la construction neuve
ou qui rentrerait aussi dans les
obligations de rovation R pour la
construction donc le problème
aujourd'hui on voit bien que les
bailleurs sont pris dans un étau entre
les obligations sur la la la rénovation
énergétique entre une dette qui qui
croit donc le le le le enfin ma question
revient quel levier pensez-vous engager
pour les les les relancer et les inciter
à à davantage de
construction alors c'était tout l'enjeu
en fait du du du du Congrès HLM à Nant
c'est-à-dire comment on tient la Renau
et la production en fait c'était c'était
ça la question euh le but du jeu c'était
pas dire tout Renault parce que on a
besoin de construire lement social je je
l'ai dit et en même temps ne pas faire
la renao c'était aussi euh voilà et donc
ce qu'on a essayé de trouver et l'idée
du pacte l'accord qu'on a obtenu avec le
mouvement Hlm c'était comment on arrive
à trouver le juste équilibre pour aider
à la fois donc il y a un certain nombre
de mesures qui ont été prises sur la
Renault la plus médiatique c'est été ce
fond de 1,2 milliards sur 3 ans mais il
y en a d'autres hein euh il y a eu euh
euh des prêts bodifiés de de la Caisse
des Dépôts euh sur la rénovation éner
étique pour de mémoire 6 milliards il y
a eu du prêt pour des changements de
vecteur
énergétique de
laadem il y a eu
[Musique]
aidez-moi sur la r vie sur la le
dispositif de la seconde vie voilà il y
a toute une série de mesures qu'on a
fait sur la Renault et toute une série
de mesures qu'on a fait sur la
production sur la production il y a 8
milliards de prébonifiés de la caisse à
à TLA - 04 sur le plai tla- 02 sur le
plus il y a
azmoi ma flangeche
euh c'est essentiellement ça voilà mais
je peux je peux je peux essayer de de
retrouver les les choses il me semblait
qu'il y avait autre chose euh donc voilà
et donc l'idée l'idée avec les les
bailleurs sociaux c'était de de de
trouver cette ce juste équilibre le but
aussi en en aidant euh à la renao c'est
de pouvoir remobiliser du du fond propre
aussi sur la production c'était ça
c'était ça le but du jeu on continue à
travailler avec le mouvement Hlm très
sincèrement on a besoin de plus de
logements sociaux
euh on a sans doute besoin aussi de de
retravailler des équilibres d'opération
moi j'en profite parce que vous avez
vous avez l'oreille des maires en tant
que sénateur et je pense enfin moi je je
l'ai dit quand j'étais allé au Congrès
des Maires du Nord euh il faut aussi que
les maires aujourd'hui accepte des
évolutions
d'opération il y a des équilibres qui
qui qui marchent peut-être plus
aujourd'hui c'estàdire qu' parfois en
rajoutant un peu de pls parfois en
rajoutant un peu de lli on peut
retrouver des équilibres d'opération
aujourd'hui je sais je connais des
maires qui qui refusent ce type
d'évolution pourtant les promoteurs ne
ne leur ment pas en l'occurrence et
aussi il faut des promoteurs pour sortir
parce que la moitié aujourd'hui des
logements locatifs sociaux se font en
VEFA donc il faut sortir des opérations
de promotion aussi il y a pas que de la
production par les bailleurs sociaux et
il y a des évolu par exemple je vous
donne les exemples il y avait une
opération de promotion toute récente
dans une ville de la région
île-de-fance il y avait de l'accession à
la propriété et du logement social euh
le promoteur est retourné voir le maire
a dit écoute il faut que tu me mettes un
peu de lli à la place de la de
l'accession à la propriété le maire a
refusé l'opération est
plantée alors qu'on la sorttitit en
faisant évoluer des opérations voilà et
donc on va pas sortir le logement social
en VEFA parce que l'opération de
promotion va pas sortir donc il y a
aussi des il faut revoir les équilibres
économiques à l'intérieur des des
produits le taux d'intérêt est ce qu'il
est et donc la nécessité d'adapter des
des programmes de promotion c'est aussi
quelque chose qu'il faut qu'il faut
intégrer voilà Frédéric Buval et
Marianne Margette on en aura terminé je
suis l'avantdernier mer madame la
Présidente merci monsieur le ministre de
nous avoir présenté ces informations cet
après-midi donc je pense que à 8000 km
la Martinique qui aura un suivi de
toutes ces annonces parce que c'est
forcément quand les annonces sont faites
à Paris c'est 5 ans après qu'on qu'on
arrivecalage donc donc je on est
vigilant làdessus une façon de vous dire
que je partage ce qu'a dit mon collègue
d'en face alors que tu habites tu es élu
sur le
territoire France métropole métropole
l'exagone on dit l'Hexagone je partage
aussi tout ce qu'a dit la collègue de la
Réunion une façon de vous dire que les
ilens euh ont tout ce qu'il faut pour ne
pas être à l'aise dans la production de
logement d'abord il y a le foncier le
foncier c'est important chez nous une
île de 15 km² 80 % de l'île est déjà en
zone agricole zone cultivé 1/3 et en
zone prévention des risques majeurs donc
c'est à out l'autre tiers c'est soumis
aux é climatiques nous nous subissons la
montée lente régulière des EAU donc on
nous propose de faire sortir des
quartiers entiers et les replacer sur ce
qu'on appelle chez nous les mornes mais
maintenant les mornes sont en zone
agricole on fait comment donc on nous a
pas donner la solution mais on n demande
de prévoir déjà la solution de les faire
sortir sur piloti peut-être tu as raison
mon cher
collègue alors le le problème qui se
pose c'est que euh les maires qui ont
une vision de développement de le
territoire ils sont pour ça d'ailleurs
quand ils se présentent à la CdP NAF
pour la révision de leur plus on leur
oppose
systématiquement ne pas toucher aux
zones agricoles et quand il y a des
opérations immobilières elles sont
bloqué puisque la CdP NAF contrairement
à la à l'Hexagone donne un avis conforme
à la Martinique et avis simple dans
l'exagone donc là aussi euh euh il y a
un petit sujet madame la Présidente
qu'il faudrait qu'on porte à cette
commission économique maintenant euh
quand
euh on dit que on met en place des
structures nous permettant de au maire
de pouvoir travailler dans la rénovation
urbaine je parle du Pvd par exemple
petite ville de demain et c'est un appel
à projet du gouvernement un appel à
projet qui ne peut satisfaire que quatre
ou cinq communes sur les 34 alors que
les 34 communes devraient être éligibles
à la rénouation urbaine maintenant c'est
très intéressant que les petites villes
de demain arrivent puisque il y a une
technicité qui est apportée par petite
ville de demain mais nous n'avons pas
encore le suivi pour savoir quand on
aura décider de faire des rénovations
urbaines qui va payer parce que les
maires vous savez très bien que dans la
par unique on est comme ici hein les les
finances communales ne sont pas
florissantes donc on n pas les moyens de
de faire cela donc euh je c'est une
question que je vous pose quel sera le
suivi des petites villes de demain et
puis euh euh quand on je parle de
rénovation urbaine je parle de ri aussi
et et là aussi nous avons toujours des
problèmes financiers pour terminer les
hchies parce que le financement n'est
pas au bout au bout du compte et surtout
pour les opérations immobilières de
leses
LLTS bon ce sont des appellations que
barbares que nous trouvons là là-bas
parce que bon tout ceux et toutes celles
qui demander à être logé l LTS peut-être
une frtion d'euros en plus ou en moins
ce qui leur permett d'aller dans un
logement une autre donc là aussi il
faudra revoir cette appellation mais
pour vous dire aussi que quand on met en
place une opération de les ou LDS les
entrepreneurs de BTP il vous tournent le
dos parce que ces opérations sont tirées
vers le bas et donc à à la fin quand il
y a l'opération est terminée
l'entrepreneur il se retrouve plus non
seulement il son touvour plus
financièrement mais les délis de
paiement puisque les opérations sont
montées de façon voilà pour commencer
mais ils attendent 6 mois avant d'être
payés donc on trouve plus
d'entrepreneurs pour construire des
logements sociaux à la Martinique alors
qu'il y a des milliers de demandes de
logement donc je vous demande comment
faites-vous comment vous allez nous
accompagner pour nous permettre de
porter la solution aux milliers de
demandes de logement sur la Martinique
merci Monsieur le Ministre non mais tout
ce que vous dites renvoie justement à
cette logique de différenciation je suis
déjà allé à Marti mais c'était pour le
tourisme je suis pas intéressé à la
situation du logement mais en tout cas
tout tout ce que vous évoquez on voit
bien que ça renvoie à toutes les
questions qu'on a déjà évoqué comment on
renforce l'ingénierie euh comment on
trouve des outils adapté à une situation
très spécifique pour le coup
euh je la solution elle est locale la
solution elle est locale
après l'état mettra en place un certain
nombre de de mesures d'accompagnement
financier dans lesquels vous allez
pouvoir piocher
mais mais c'est pas moi à Paris qui vais
trouver la solution pour la Martinique
hein ça c'est clair he c'est c'est c'est
c'est c'est des questions véritablement
d'aménagement urbain local et de
stratégie et de vision de développement
territorial voilà mais en tout cas on
sera à vos côté pour pour accompagner et
trouver les les bons outils mais voilà
alors Marianne Margaté et je suis
désolée on a zappé Daniel gréer qui
achèvera le cycle des questions voilà
rapidement merci madame la Présidente
donc monsieur le ministre je vous
parliez tout à l'heure de l'équilibre
des opérations je pense qu'avec la
flambée des taux d'intérêt ça repose en
tout cas moi ça repose la question
d'aide à la pierre je v vous donner un
exemple j'ai inauguré dans ma commune je
suis sénatrice de sa etmarne une
opération de 12 logements en tissus
urbain petite opération qui respecte
voilà un peu maintenant le les schémas
de développement que nous souhaitons
pour notre pays et sur cette OP
le financement de l'État c'est 0,8 %
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui en tant que
nos bailleurs sont confrontés de toute
façon à c'est du logement social hein on
s'entend bien évidemment donc sont
confrontés à l'impossibilité de mener à
bien leur construction donc c'est un
véritable blocage en terme de
construction de logements sociaux c'est
une priorité on en est tous d'accord
mais la disparition de l'aide à la
pierre pose la question de cet équilibre
économique je voulais vous parler
également de différenciation et la
question a été évoquée euh sur le PTZ
moi je suis élu donc dans un grand
département la moitié de l'île-de-fance
partie très urbaine partie en
développement et partie très rurale euh
et je pense que le
PTZ aurait pu en tout cas pourrait euh
être mieux différencié notamment dans
nos zones tendues qui sont euh à l'ouest
de la scèemarne mais qui qui correspond
aussi à d'autres départements pour
permettre notamment l'IND enfin le la
possibilité d'activer le PTS le PTZ pour
de l'individuel neuf en BRSA et en PSLA
qui qui correspond à une attente très
clair des populations qui qui souhaitent
s'implanter dans des communes et qui
peut permettre de fluidifier le parcours
résidentiel que que que nous souhaitons
mettre en place et également être
attentif au à l'élargissement du PTZ
dans des zone non tendue pour du neuf
lorsqu'il n'y a pas de logement ancien
disponible et dans notre notre grande
couronne de l'Île-de-France on est
parfois sur des situations de forte
tension dans lequel il n'y a plus de
logement ancien et pour autant il y a
une volonté de pouvoir accueillir de de
nouvelles populations et enfin pour
rester en Île-de-France comme ça c'est
un peu moins c'est une île mais c'est
pas les aussi belle ni que la Réunion ni
que celle de de de l'outreem en général
je voulais vous poser la question sur la
volonté de la présidente de la région
î-de-fance madame pcrè d'imposer un un
seuil minimal de de 30 % de logements
sociaux en plai en plus sinon les
communes seraient empêchées de
construire du logement social ça pose
question puisque quand même on parle de
développement de logement social et
c'est quand même un peu une libre
atteinte à à la à la libre
administration et au choix des communes
donc je voulais avoir votre avis sur
cette question apparemment les services
de l'État sont assez réticents sur cette
mesure dite
antigetto est-ce que vous partagez
quelle est votre position et comment
vous estimez la quelle est votre analyse
sur la fragilité juridique d'une telle
mesure si elle venait à s'appliquer je
vous
remercie
merci sur la première opération que que
vous avez écoutez j'ai annoncé au
Congrès HLM qu'on avait encore des des
crédits disponibles au titre du FNAP et
que on devait les utiliser en priorité
pour débloquer les opérations qui
restent bloqué donc
envoyez-moi l'équilibre de de
l'opération on a peut-être des crédits
app à compléter pour pouvoir équilibrer
l'opération on a fait passer le message
à tous les préfets euh on a vu qu'il y
avait des opérations qui avaient un
petit peu de mal à à se débloquer qui
manquait finalement pas grand-chose il
reste du FNAP allez-y quoi donc soit
interpellerz le préfet soit envoyez-nous
la chose on regardera ça sur le pré à
zéro il est ouvert à l'ensemble de
l'accession sociale quel que soit le la
zone sur tout le territoire national
PSLA BRS l'accession le le PTZ est
ouvert oui indidu si en individuel voilà
il est ouvert en accession sociale le
PTZ est ouvert accession sociale il est
ouvert voilà sur toute l'accession
sociale vous l'avez dans le dans le PLF
là donc PSLA BRS éligible il y a pas de
souci et après sur la position de la de
la présidente de la région Île-de France
[Musique]
euh je je je pense qu'en
fait et c'est pour ça que je moi moi
j'aspire à à ce débat qu'on doit avoir
sur c'est quoi le logement social
demain tout à l'heure je me suis exprimé
j'ai donné une conception un peu
personnelle de ce que pouvait être enfin
en tout cas c'est mon point de vue sur
la façon dont pourrait évoluer le
logement social demain si on dit demain
si on dit donc je fais de la fiction là
c'est la loi logement elle y est pas on
est dans une concertation et un échange
libre si demain on dit que le logement
social il doit trouver l'équilibre entre
le travailleur clé le
soignant et les ménages précaires je
suis pas sûr que la présidente de la
réionelle- de- France maintienne ça j'en
suis pas certain
euh je je je peut-être que peut-être que
ce débat on doit peut-être le dépasser
par le haut et et se dire qu'est-ce qui
nous réunirait ensemble des élus de la
République sur la fonction du L social
on doit finalement peut-être excusez-moi
l'expression mais faire la paix entre
nous sur le logement social et trouver
finalement une vocation du logement
social qui réunirait suffisamment d'él
de la République autour d'une
conception est-ce que on peut ne pas
être je sais pas moi 80 % des élus de la
République d'accord avec un modèle
généraliste qui équilibre les
travailleurs clés et et les plus
précaires donc peut-être donc moi j'ai
envie de ce don j'ai envie c'est
peut-être reposer la question du du
modèle du logement social et faire qu'il
soit peut-être réapproprié par nos mères
moi je suis toujours gêné quand je vois
des mère s'opposer à la construction du
logement social je suis toujours gêné ça
me gêne c'est c'est je je comprends pas
pourquoi c'est voilà il y a un modèle
républicain qui est le nôtre et cetera
alors peut-être qu'on doit en débattre
collectivement peut-être
qu'effectivement aujourd'hui le modèle
du logement social est peut-être on a
peut-être pas réussi à rassembler assez
autour du modèle du logement social et
si on essayit de trouver un modèle qui
rassemble plus d'élus de la République
et du coup on pour qu'on puisse
développer sans contrainte il y en aura
toujours un petit peu he mais en tout
cas que on ait une une définition du
logement social qui soit plus partagé
est-ce qu'on peut réussir dans ce pays à
dépassionner le logement social et se
dire que il est nécessaire à nos
concitoyens voilà c'est c'est mon rêve
je finis sur un rêve une utopie ah non
il y a une autre question suis désolé
monsieur le ministre Dani gr encore
toutes nos excuses oui madame présidente
monsieur ministre presque ça et je suis
vraiment désolé parce que je vais casser
un peu votre
rve parce que la réalité monsieur le
ministre vous la connaissez comme
nous si vous la connaissez comme nous la
réalité c'est que l'envoler des prix des
matériaux fait qu'aujourd'hui le nombre
de particuliers de communes on est tous
confrontés on est sur le terrain comme
vous qui renonce parce qu'ils ont pas
les capacités aujourd'hui de financer la
rénovation énergétique je parle même pas
du du neu y compris la rénovation et
quand on sait le mur qui a devant nous
et vous l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure à
juste titre des du calendrier des
logements qui vont sortir et cetera
encore faut-il avoir les moyens on n'
pas une politique d'accompagnement qui
permette à des familles de pouvoir faire
face au moyens et à l'accroissement des
coûts de R inovation je suis désolé
c'est la réalité des fait aujourd'hui
tout le monde est mobilisé sur
l'inflation alimentaire mais regardez
l'inflation des coûts que représente
aujourd'hui le
logement une question aujourd'hui la
loisane va effectivement
restreindre la possibilité de construire
donc on a l'obligation de pouvoir
reconquérir du bâti qui n'a plus de
vocation et je prends l' exemple dans le
milieu rural et on est tous confrontés à
ça d'anciennes fermes qui n'ont plus de
vocation et aujourd'hui la fiscalité est
différente quand vous rénovez la partie
logement de la partie du bâti l'ancienne
étable l'ancienne stockage de foin peu
importe la il y a un gros problème
pourtant c'est pour faire du logement et
vous ne permettez pas là encore
l'accessibilité à des familles de
pouvoir s'investir dans la rénovation
deuxième exemple que je vrais donner
dans les communes on a un gros problème
aussi de bien qui n'ont plus de vocation
économique mais comme il y a pas de
fiscalité B personne ne veut vendre et
donc effectivement euh j'ai bien entendu
et je partage ce que vous avez dit tout
à l'heure mais encore faut-il qu' est le
droit de préemption c'est bien à à
condition que les propriétaire acceptte
de vendre et pour inciter les gens à à
vendre B je suis désolé il faut y mettre
de la fiscalité euh pour oublier pour
faire permettre pu que un certain nombre
de propriétaires se rendent compte que
ce serait mieux de vendre que de
continuer de payer des des biens qui ne
servent plus à rien qui sont des verrues
souvent dans des villages voire dans des
villes c'est pas uniquement dans le
milieu rural voilà mes questions alors
je suis désolé d'avoir gâché un peu
votre arrêt non vous vous gâchez rien du
tout non je voulais faire une envolée
pour
euh l'accompagnement des des des ménages
très modestes le maprim Renov 2024 que
que c'est 90 % pour les ménages très
modestes l'aide l'aide publique pardon
j'ai pas entendu je parle pas que des
faut pas se mobiliser que sur Non non
mais je je j'entends non mais j'entends
mais non non le choix qui est fait
aujourd'hui c'est de veiller
effectivement à ce que les ménages Tron
ne pas exclu de ça on est passé là on
est à 5 milliards maintenant sur la
rénovation énergétique des des logements
le PLF qui est devant vous c'est 5
milliards sur sur l'aide de l'ANA c'est
peut-être pas terminé c'estd qu'on se
retrouvera peut-être au PLF 25 et on
aura peut-être encore une augmentation
on voit que c'est la tendance de toute
façon moi je note quand même une chose
aujourd'hui ce que que vous disiez je
connais mon territoire aujourd'hui moi
c'est pas forcément d'ailleurs l'argent
qui bloque le plus chez moi c'est les
entreprises et les diagnostiqueurs donc
il y a la filière économique aussi aussi
à monter qui peut être aussi un obstacle
à la rénovation énergétique donc oui il
y a des obstacles la question du coût
est un obstacle vous avez raison et même
prenez donz par exemple les logements
locatifs si vous faites aujourd'hui de
l'isolation par l'intérieur parce que
votre façade vous pouvez pas et cetera
comme vous n'avez pas encore de
technologie avancée sur les isolants
minces il y a le SGPI qui travaille
là-dessus et qui accompagne mais comme
la technologie aujourd'hui donc vous
avez une épaisseur vous perdez de la
surface de votre logement et donc vous
perdez du loyer donc effectivement la
question du modèle économique de la
rénovation aujourd'hui il n'est pas il
est pas complet il est pas il est pas
fait il est pas parfait la perfection
serait de financer tous les travaux pour
tout le monde mais effectivement on en
est pas là aujourd'hui ce que je vois
c'est l'effort qui est fait l'évolution
qui me semble aller quand même dans le
bon sens et au moins de ne pas oublier
ces ménages très modestes aujourd'hui et
d'ailleurs je fais une petite parenthèse
quand on parlait tout à l'heure des DPE
dans le parc privé n'oublions pas aussi
que ramener un DPEG vers un DPE ou d
c'est la facture énergétique du
locataire qui tombe fortement et au
moment où où on on est en train de
parler des dépenses énergétiques
considérables aujourd'hui un locataire
en paye des factures énergétiques
insupportable donc la rénovation
énergétique c'est aussi du gain de
pouvoir d'achat c'est aussi du confort
et donc à un moment donné il faut y
aller donc effectivement je reconnais
avec vous que sans doute que l'aide sera
jamais à la hauteur de l'attente mais en
tout cas elle va vers le haut et et on
continue à accompagner et je trouve que
par exemple l'ambition qui est donnée
sur la rénovation globale est une
ambition positive est-ce qu'on est à la
fin de ça non on est au tout début d'un
processus à mon avis il y en a encore
pour quelques années devant nous je
pense que la rénovation on n'a pas fini
donc voilà je pense qu'on a on a devant
nous on a devant nous un beau chantier
donc il il y a sans doute pas l'aide
qu'on imagine sur la question de de la
vacance
euh aujourd'hui il y a des outils la
taxe sur les logements vacants par
exemple moi je l'utilise à fond dans la
commune de V à fond hein on a mis euh
quand c'est du logement quand c'est du
logement c'est vra quand c'est du
logement ou oui qu c'est pas du logement
c'est c'est plus complexe mais à la
limite pourquoi pas pourquoi pas on
débattre dans la loi logement pourquoi
pas pourquoi pas à la limite étendre le
le à quoi faudrait-il étendre la taxe
sur les logements vacants et puis il y a
une autre question derrière qu'on aura
aussi dans la loi logement faut-il
déplafonner le taux de la taxe sur les
logements vacants et donner la
possibilité au aux autorités
organisatrices de l'habitat demain de
fixer librement la taxe sur les
logements vacan moi j'ai eu par exemple
la mère de Calais qui m'a appelé qui m'a
dit qui m'a posé cette question est-ce
que je moi je voilà j'ai un gros
problème de logement vacant au centre de
Calais j'ai envie d'augmenter très
fortement la tax sur les logements
vacants et je veux travailler à fond
là-dessus et cetera n' avait pas la
possibilité de par la loi aujourd'hui
voilà est-ce que demain dans le cadre de
la loi logement on donne cette outil
demain et éventuellement élargi à
d'autres euh à d'autres équipements ou à
d'autres bâtiments que les logements
pourquoi pas en tout cas ça doit faire
partie de notre réflection et c'est l'un
des outils notamment pour tous ces
maires qui sont confrontés à beaucoup de
vacances merci merci du fond du cœur
monsieur le ministre parce que vous nous
avez consacré plus de 2 heures à ces
échanges qui ont été passionnants mais
on a compris aussi à travers vos
interventions qu'on serait amené de
nouveau à à échanger avec vous sur de
très nombreux sujets soit d'ors et déjà
des PPL qui vont arriver à l'Assemblée
nationale mais surtout sur cette grande
loi logement où vous nous avez dit qu'on
débattrait on débattrait pratiquement de
tous les sujets si j'ai bien
compris voilà mais quand même vous nous
avez ouvert bon nombre de de portes en
tout cas merci beaucoup beaucoup et
bonne soirée merci à tous les collègues
demain matin 9h l'audition de madame la
secrétaire d'État à la politique de la
ville